at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
o yeah I got that's what it is all right
now you got to look at the lighting and
the position of the camera and [__] with
it okay let me see oh that shit's
[__] wrong see I know that shit's
[__] wrong I knew it you want it
right about at the top of that see how
that's right you want that right there
okay that way the mirror is at the upper
Edge okay see that and then the center
of the mirror is in the center of this
just dress right
dress way a man
does I was like I didn't move it I
didn't move it from earlier so so it's
not my fault this
time all right let's see who's here
don't be so silly we're going talk about
Michael Jackson today it could be a good
show yeah Ben said I hope there'll be a
poll on whether people think MJ was
guilty or framed by grifters oh man
honestly you know what um I kind of like
the more I delved into this kind of
stuff um I kind of feel like why not
both because I'm I'm not saying because
those two options are not mutually
exclusive um which we kind which I want
to get into a little bit but I'm just
kind of like um I don't know I I
initially thought I don't know what I
thought about it like initially before I
really look too much into it I said well
he's kind of a weirdo and stuff but yeah
maybe people are just kind of you know
making it up a little like trying to get
money or something but then like the
more I looked into it I was
like I think maybe he did that [__] I
think maybe he did that [__] but I you
know what I mean I'm not sure I I don't
I don't know and he's dead so he can't
there's a guy that I uh subscribed
to on YouTube he's got a real good
channel does like metal reviews and uh
he he'll do
commentary and um for a heavy metal guy
he he he's he's a fan of Michael Jackson
he likes Michael
Jackson and uh he did a whole show on
it he think he thought that the evidence
pointed towards that he was being set up
by people in in the Hollywood scene that
use their kids as bait and then sue you
because they had like a a couple of them
had that history of
that so yeah that was happening that
doesn't mean that [__] Michael wasn't
[__] didling them boys that's what I
mean it's like yeah those both those
things could be true because I think
particularly when we get into the case
of um Jordan Chandler who was the first
kid um you know that came out in the in
1990 1993
um and even though his dad was allegedly
um you know uh trying to get money out
of Michael that doesn't mean that could
just mean that he was using the fact
that his son had been molested for real
um to get to like cash out you know what
I mean which I think is probably what
happened that doesn't mean that he made
that up right that you know but that
means that when he heard about it he's
like oh I can use that to like cash in
you know like ch- Ching so yeah
evidently there's there's a subculture
that was of parasites hanging around
Hollywood scene back in these days
probably still going on who knew who all
the [__] all the pedos were and would
use their kids as bait to entrap them
yeah that was and that sounds I believe
that because there it was evidently the
same families over and over again the
same kids in certain cases so there are
some evil people out there that have
children
yeah that will use their kids to get
money well and I was that in that way
well okay let me answer this question
because Bryce Versa asked a long time
ago yeah said to be blunt how do I find
your many vids oh yeah okay yeah um what
is our many vids called I think it's
called it's either called 13 cam or it's
called gen Tom cam no gen Tom cam is our
stream I know but I don't know if I
named it the same I think I got it you
probably know what it's called I can't
even remember what it's
called but
um I think I got it here it's uh 13 cam
okay I'll show you Tammy says you should
look into Cory Feldman also it's you
know what um I saw like um I was
watching some documentaries about this
earlier and Corey
Feldman uh there was a clip of him
saying that when he he was at Michael
Jackson's apartment like his house or
whatever when he was I guess he was 13
yeah and he said that Michael Jackson
showed him this book that he had that
was like all naked people but they had
like they had like sexually transmitted
diseases and he was like showing it to
like a 13-year-old kid yeah speaking of
STDs our [__] V midi vids Channel no
I was
kidding it was it's actually 13 cam
spelled out it's not the number 13 it's
it's spelled out 13 cam it's all Min vid
you'll see it and the videos are about a
few months back of
um they're good they're good but better
stuff's
coming you know Jen's been in training
and she looks [__] real good lately
man um she was good then she's even
better now she's gonna be a super cougar
in about two months super cougar super
cou brace versus says for research
research purp yeah yeah I need to start
like uploading more stuff yeah it's
funny we were we were streaming and and
there's a customer that's just kind of
hanging out and thinking you know he's
asking questions oh by the way I love
your other show show yeah like oh okay
yeah yeah okay you know yeah it was just
like I think it was like a British guy
or something he goes oh okay yeah you're
a fan of the show like yeah yeah I just
had to stop by stop by and talk to for a
little while just I got to go to work
though it's okay you know come back when
you're ready yeah we'll jerk you
off I mean you
know [__] funny yeah it is we're not
sensitive about that people we're yeah
we're really not don't get don't get
bashful we we're not we're we're
professionals about it it's like being
part of the carnival and we're not
Studio porn stars we're not [__]
other people it's just each other just
we're just doing [__] we'd be doing
anyway right exactly so it's more like a
peep show letting you see yeah I think
it's kind of it's kind of more like that
yeah than yeah yeah cuz like I said
we're not just like pimping ourselves
out to like random ass people or
anything yeah Ben says blackmail has
been a thing as long as the music
industry has existed yeah and like I
said I kind of get I get that people
said it's like oh well people are just
trying to get money out of him and I'm
not denying that cuz I know for sure at
least Evan Chandler like Jordan Jordan
Chandler's dad um he seemed well they
have like a phone we'll get into this
but they have like a recorded phone call
of him like talking to his son's stepdad
because the he you know he had they
divorced and he had and she had
remarried remarried and um you know he's
very clearly trying to get he's like I
hired this lawyer and he's going to like
you know humiliate Michael Jackson and
all this other kind of [__] so he
definitely was trying to get a payout
but like I said that doesn't necessarily
mean that the allegations that the kid
came forward with weren't true and
honestly here's the crazy thing and like
I said I watched a bunch of different
stuff about this and the [__] that
Michael Jackson was open
about was crazy like he would just like
the the kid that I'm talking about um
Jordan Chandler the first kid that came
forward Michael Jackson was at like the
world music award
in I think it was in
Monaco and this 13-year-old boy he like
made him sit on his lap who does that
and like and it's weird and the kid
looks kind of like uncomfortable I'm
going to say like I really like who has
a 13-year-old boy like a grown man has a
13-year-old boy sit on their lap it's
just very strange and there and there
was some other stuff too with um that
one kid Gavin the kid that had um
cancer and uh there's like there's video
of Michael Jackson and that kid and the
kid is just like is snuggling up again
and he was also like 13 or 14 and
they're like holding hands and stuff
it's bizarre yeah they're it's almost
like and I kind of want to get into this
too because it does seem like he had
like
romances with these boys
yeah look Razer fist didn't think any of
this happened okay he thought it was all
black
mail uh one of the things that he used
it to to to
in his defense was is that Cory what his
name Cory Felding his name Feldman Cy
Feldman defended Jackson says Jackson
wasn't doing any of
that got to understand that some of the
some of the kids that defended Jackson
said that wasn't going on were sleeping
with him they were his
boyfriends yeah okay you say well how
could you be a boyfriend when you hear
the stories about how he would do it he'
groom him over time okay yeah and he did
it in a way that is very indicative I
watched this really good video it was
like an hour and a half and she was
talking about she's like people have a
misperception about pedophiles or PDF
files as they as they call them to get
around PDF file which I always thought
which I thought was really funny we're
call him PDF file we're call PF that's
just funny that's a good one yeah that's
just funny yeah they're not mean well
some of them are but it's like but the
the kind that he probably was um and and
the fact that he always would say like
whenever he was on they showed like all
these different CS of him you know on
news programs and people you know the
people like Diane Sawyer and stuff like
that would like ask him straight out
it's like did you do this did you
sexually molest these boys and stuff he
would always say the same thing I would
never harm a child yeah and I was like
maybe he's not lying like because
probably in his mind he doesn't think
he's hurting them and like if you watch
Leaving Neverland which is um
uh two of the guys it's actually really
good it's on HBO Max and um the two guys
that are on that uh that say that they
were molested they are kind of [__] up
about it because they're like it wasn't
there like there was nothing aggressive
about it there wasn't like he wasn't
mean he wasn't anything like that and
it's like they were so young that and
they were hanging out with this super
famous person and just like having him
slowly um getting them to do different
things just like well this is what
people do when they love love each other
and blah blah like it was that kind of
thing so it's like it was a really like
slow prog didn't think he was they
didn't the the the boys didn't didn't
see it as being
hurt he groomed him he flipped him
flipped him slowly he was a smooth
criminal yeah Jackson was evidently
smooth um
now you know that I I am a great student
of male behavior and a professor of male
Behavior a professor of male Behavior as
well being a boist and being a biologist
everything you know [__] a doctor of
bology uh when you look at Michael
Jackson This The
Superficial appearances of where he
lived in his environment is is not
typically male okay statues of little
white boys everywhere little Peter Pans
and [__] [__] Ferris wheels and crap
and this guy's a 30-year-old [__]
Mega
star single
a 30-year-old single mega mega star with
a palace and grounds like that doesn't
have [__] statues of little boys and
[__] it's got porn stars in it and
[__] Jets and [__] landing pads
and [__] nightclubs and it on it on
his compound and you know they're going
to have adult [__] movie stars over
and
[__] big
parties you know he'd have a herum
basically that's not what he had he had
just a bunch of little boys and stuff
that if your neighbor had in his front
yard if your if your neighbor was a 60
5-year-old fat white dude and he's got a
ferris wheel in his F he's got no wife
or children or anything he's got a
ferris wheel in his [__] front yard
with the [__] video games and he's
trying to get all the little
neighborhood boys to come over and
[__] play video games with him you'd
be he'd be calling the cops that's yeah
and I and I and a lot of people have
pointed that out it's like if a dude was
doing that [__] yeah absolutely
everybody would be like stay away from
that [__] creeper so I'm seeing it
just just the superficial aspects of
where he lived and who he surrounded and
it was
suspicious but then the other night when
I'm hearing this this long story from
that kid what was his name you just
mentioned from that program well no the
the ones that were grown up that were
talking on there yeah were um that was
oh [__] what his name um I'll think of
him in a minute that's what I'm saying
he was a kid when it happened yeah but
he one of them's name is Wade and then
the other one's name's a couple of them
right James man James when when you hear
their stories it's like then all of a
sudden it's typical male pattern
behavior for Jackson Jackson's doing
typical male behavior in terms of
forming a herum having a hierarchy
inside the herum [__] replacing the
old ones and [__] putting in new ones
he's he's he's doing what guys do to sex
objects or girlfriends basically well
and that's what kind of struck me about
a lot of the clips and that he wasn't
even hiding the clip like he would have
like they did a documentary um when he
was hanging out with Gavin because Gavin
and the F and Gavin's family was living
there with him at Neverland and so they
did a documentary called living with
Michael Jackson and it was supposed to
like make him look better I guess but
just the way that he sat with that boy
and the way that they're like holding
hands and the way they're just like it
just seemed really weird it seemed more
like a boyfriend girlfriend yeah he's
got and he's got all these kids of
various ages surrounding him up on stage
and they're all dressed in Michael
Jackson Styles and [__] like that it's
weird it's weird and then they're
staying and he's he's talking the
parents into letting them spend the
night for like
months well yeah it's not like they
spend the night one night no they're
going to be over there like for months
well that Wade kid Mo the whole family
to down the road and then he's paying we
got to get into we'll get into he buying
them houses and [__] like that I said
that W that was on leaving Neverland I
mean they he was Australian yeah him and
his mom and sister moved to the United
States like so that Michael Jackson
could help him out he's like yeah you
have to come to LA and like you know
what I mean to come to California I'll
help out your career or whatever a rich
powerful PDF file is going to uh make
friends with the family and pay him off
basically now some of the family members
are going to say going to be like well
we didn't realize that was happening but
then evidently in Hollywood there are
families that know exactly that's what
happens they're trying to hook their
kids up with these PDF files so they can
get a free house well so they can have
and especially because a lot of the boys
that he you know interfered with if you
want to call it that um you know were in
the entertainment industry they were
actors or dancers or something like that
so they had like their parents had a
vested interest too in in uh
facilitating a relationship because
Michael Jackson could help their kid out
like with a career you know what I mean
and the and the families were getting
[__] too they were getting flown all
over the world and they got to go on
tour with him and one of them like one
family they he bought him my house and
all this other kind of [__] and what's
funny is that he gets rid of
them and they're they're all good-look
kids but he gets rid of them as soon as
they're old enough to really kind of
like start attract the interest of just
like a regular gay dude soon as they get
that old he's got to get rid of them
yeah that's the pattern like I said I
was watching a thing about different
kinds of PDF files or like like what
kind he was specifically and cuz Ben
said I think he was just very immature
and thought of himself as a young boy
that is the case a lot of PDF files like
that well that's what I mean and that's
kind of what like cuz this woman was
going through like I said it was like an
hour and a half long video and she went
through like all these different like
law enforcement books for like um you
know profiling like PDF files and stuff
like that and that's one of the things
cuz I think that that was something that
a lot of like his fans would use to like
excuse it it's like oh well it's just
like being with another kid but it's
like yeah but that's that's a red flag
of that's what PDF files do yeah some a
certain brands of a certain kinds of
them because there's a couple different
like kinds but one kind in particular
and there was a big a big long thing
about it like in these books and stuff
like that where it's just kind of like
they can't relate to adults at all they
feel like they're young they want to be
they want to hang out with children and
relate to children on their own level
and you know do kids stuff like they
don't want to grow up that's very very
common and that's like exactly what he
was like you know what I mean so that
was like really enlightening like
watching that because yeah and like I
said as soon as they start getting old
enough to be interesting to mainstream
gays they he loses all interest that's
and it's weird then he uh then he asked
them and then and then all of a
sudden he has a weird he had a weird
thing where the dudes would once they
got to that age once they got older they
were dating girls and he wanted to know
all about the girls too Michael did yeah
but he I I I don't think he was jealous
though I think he was curious maybe I
don't think he was jealous I I think he
liked
straight
boys yeah what he
liked I think he saw himself as straight
it's weird man I don't know how I don't
know how I don't think he was though no
he was but I think I think Michael
Jackson saw himself as straight he
seemed terrified of women I heard one
and this was from his own mouth like
this was from an interview when he was
in his 20s I think he was 23 24
something like that I think he kind of
briefly quote unquote dated Tatum O'Neal
who I think was 19 at the time I
remember that and she was like want to
jump on the dick right like you know
she's a 19-year old girl yeah so she
goes over his house and she starts like
unbuttoning his shirt or something and
he like freaked out he like put his
hands over his face like that and that's
from him that's he said that yeah and
she left she was like okay yeah well
he's childish right I think he's I think
he saw himself as a straight child yeah
and he's fooling around with little boys
I mean why I mean why do you think the
ranch is called Neverland and there's
like Peter Pan [__] everywhere and he
and he said on multiple occasions that
he that that was like his he didn't say
it was a spirit animal but like he
wanted to like like young forever I saw
his little train he got a train station
and [__] and everything and when when
you get when you disembark from the
[__]
train you go down these stairs and on
either side of the stair on one side of
the stairs there's this beautiful bronze
statue of like a Peter Pan drinking out
of a out of the water I think drinking
off the edge of a rock it looked like
that damn White Rock [__] logo off
the soda and that statue was thousand
and thousands of dollars and [__] like
that was everywhere but you're looking
at that and you go
like what's the black dude got that 30-y
old black dude got that for you know why
isn't that some big fine [__] sister
up there like a stallion big old booty
you know what me that's what really
should be there and then he's modifying
his face really to look like a little
white
boy he looks a little white yeah it did
it that whole situation was like really
weird to he was transracial
and according and I don't know if this
is true or not because a lot of the
stuff is just kind of you know hearsay
or just like somebody saying some [__]
but according to a couple of people who
worked for him they said that Michael
Jackson absolutely did not like black
people at all it doesn't surprise me I
believe he was
transracial you know and like and he
would even like and he would say like
real shitty stuff about that yeah do
doubt I don't doubt it so I don't know
if that's true I don't think he lik his
family much too much either well yeah
they were kind of arranged a little bit
I mean I can't blame him in that regard
because I do because his father
especially was like real abusive um you
know and he really was wasn't uh shy of
talking about that like and especially
like when you know when they were kids
and they were doing the Jackson Five and
everything like he would just like beat
the crap out of them like if they messed
up and be like it's cuz I love children
and I'm doing this for the children then
you look at look at him up there looking
at you look at him and he's up there on
stage with these children right with
there's no girls there's no little girls
and there's no black boys it's all these
little white boys the only only the only
children yeah probably he probably had
some tokens up there to kind get Emanuel
Lewis like remember little Emanuel Le
from yeah yeah okay from Webster
remember that kid yeah there was no
black there so when he thinks of
children he's thinking of little white
boys little white children yeah little
white boys not girls little white boys
yeah cuz it's not no girls up there and
another claim that that one of his uh I
who I think used to be his personal
assistant and this is all alleged I
don't know if this any is true or not
but she said she like part of her job
was to go through like all the letters
and stuff that people like fans had sent
him and she said that he would go
through there and didn't even if the if
the letters if they if you could tell it
was from like a girl or like a black kid
or something like that like he didn't
even bother just throw
that he just threw away he only wanted
the whites and the Asians and the
Latinos yeah uh apparently
allegedly I don't know if that's true
but that's what the oh it would fit
that's what um that's what she said it
would fit yeah so I I don't know if
that's the case yeah based on my psycho
analysis of him and you know the the
skin whitening thing um you know a lot
of people have said and like they said
that he had you know
Vitiligo which maybe I don't know maybe
but the thing about it there there are
some pictures of him before he went full
white man yeah where he had his shirt
off
and he doesn't look like he has viago
now I know that you can get that like he
doesn't look patchy looks normal so um I
guess I mean you can develop that later
so maybe he did and because I think his
family said that he had it but I think
that he started lightening his skin to
even it all out you know what I mean I
don't buy it I don't know I don't buy it
I believe I believe that he was just a
normal black guy in terms of just
physical and he was also he used to say
too that PDF like his dad would used to
make fun of like how wide his nose was
and like how he looked like because he
was real cute when he was a kid and then
when he got a little bit older like as a
teenager like his dad started talking
about like how ugly he was like he
didn't look right anymore and [__] like
that he was fine he didn't it was I know
and that well that's what I mean but he
was really apparently really [__] up
about it so it's like clearly so I I
think maybe that fed into him not
wanting to look like himself anymore and
then he ended up just and you know and
you can't really believe everything he
says because according to him he only
had three plastic surgeries like on his
face you can't believe anything Michael
Jackson says like he said that he had
two nose jobs and they and like a thing
to put a cleft in his chain but I was
like it looks like more than that to me
had I'm just saying eventually they did
that nose too many times and can't put
it back when you take too much off they
told him that he shouldn't do it again
but he kept he kept cutting it off
cutting pieces of it off yeah
I don't know the truth of it but I had
heard that they had to implant some
wires inside there keep it from
collapsing to keep it from collapsing I
don't know if that's the case or not but
yeah I mean a wire endoskeleton right to
hold it in place that's crazy yeah yeah
Tammy said just because he didn't touch
every boy doesn't mean he didn't touch
anybody yeah that's another thing too is
that I know that a lot of people will
come out and say like mcau culin for
example like who he hung out with a lot
um m is very vocal about like defending
him and saying like no nothing ever
happened but you know and I'm not saying
you know I obviously I wasn't there so
it's like I don't know if anything
happened to mcau culan and he just
doesn't want to deal with it or if
really nothing happened to him because I
will say that the two guys that were in
leaving NE Neverland um they too denied
like because they got called as
Witnesses in the 1993 trial like um the
Jordan Chandler one and they got called
as Witnesses because they'd spent a lot
of time with Michael Jackson and they
denied it at the time too and really
they only came out in like
2019 and said what happened and they had
you know people can say oh why are you
saying it now and blahy blah but it's
just kind of like I don't know I thought
they had like pretty decent
justifications and they both seem kind
of they they both seem really really
kind of mentally messed up because of it
I mean they didn't even like they didn't
even tell their wives they didn't you
know until later they just denied it
denied it denied it and then finally it
was was [__] them up so bad mentally
that they finally just admitted it you
know what I mean yeah Allison's asked me
if I'm okay I don't know what she's
talking about a long time ago I don't
know what she's referring
to Zach says I'm still just so amused
that maybe the world's most famous
singer ever came from dullest [__]
dishwater Indiana of all goddamn places
yeah Gary Indiana that's where he's from
which is crazy yeah I'd always forgot
that I forgot that he was a Jehovah's
Witness too you know yeah and I
apparently he stayed a Jehovah's Witness
his whole life even though I think they
gave him crap like for the Thriller
video cuz that wasn't kosher with them I
guess like when that came out in
1984 but I don't think he ever
renounced that uh Faith so I don't you
know I don't know that's another thing
that's kind of weird about it but I he
didn't really get up in anyone's face
about it I guess but man those cats are
making so much noise out there they're
chasing each other around
yeah yeah Alison said my nose is crooked
but I'm not getting surgery yeah oh oh
he's referring to Smooth Criminal oh
okay
yeah yeah that's what he was talking
about I think that's what he was talking
he was a smooth criminal you've been hit
by you've been struck by a smooth
criminal that's a great song actually it
is a good song yeah and no one's saying
that he's not like a brilliant singer
and a brilliant dancer and everything
like that obviously but like I said it
can be both things he can also have been
and I legitimately like I
said I don't know cuz whenever he
whenever he was asked Point Blank
because I saw like a bunch of different
clips of interviews where different you
know uh news people asked him Point
Blank like if the allegations were true
like did you molest children and he
always says the same thing he always
says I would never harm a child that's
how he answers it yeah and I said and I
don't think
I think that he really thinks that he's
not hurting them yeah well I heard the
testimony testimony is not evidence but
I heard the testimony from the boy both
those boys but yeah and U he was his you
those people don't understand they're
ignorant you know if they find out we're
going to both go to jail you don't want
to see me go to jail they he's one of
those kind of guy you know I love you
that kind of [__] he was
not one of these kind of guys who's
going to
[__] strong arm some kid or terrorize
him he wasn't like that he' try to win
him
over yeah and he was in love with him I
believe yeah it did seem like that yeah
but there was limits to that it had to
be within a certain framework you got
too old he got rid of
you and he was a two-timer too yeah
wasn't just one kid you know they were
saying that yeah he'd go upstairs with
him and he'd come back an hour later and
you go up with another one and he goes
and I knew that that was B that was my
time to go up there you know yeah it was
that kind of well that's kind of [__]
up about these two kids cuz they were
saying you know they were young you know
and they were just this like I said it's
Michael Jackson he's one of the most
famous people in the world and it's like
and he's paying attention to you and
he's like hanging out with you and like
he think and you know you feel like
you're the center of his universe and
all this other kind of stuff and they're
like and it's [__] up but it's kind of
awesome so it's like when he goes and
spends time with another kid even though
he's probably like molesting them too
you're like God damn it you know what I
mean like they get jealous yeah and he's
like and I you know and then now that
they're adults they're like I just can't
process like how [__] up that is yeah
but yeah that dude that dude he
explicitly said that he said I knew what
what they were doing up there yeah you
know he was getting jealous and [__]
yeah cuz he's like that was you know
what that what we did and that was
supposed to be super special that's my
time so it's just kind of like that yeah
the [__] they described was see that's
the thing they never did let's you know
if we're going to get graphic about it I
don't think he ever like did like anal
he tried now he did try
yeah with one of the like when he was he
said that was the last time he saw him
yeah I think it was Wade yeah and he
said that the last time he supposed to
see him and at this point he was 15
maybe something like that um and he said
he did try to like I don't did he say
that he tried to stick his penis in his
butt or his finger I think he said no I
it was his dick I think it was both I
think but then he said it was just it
was too painful so so he stopped doing
it but it seemed like most mostly what
they would do was like mutual
masturbation yeah and oral oral making
out yeah like making out like you know
oh let me kiss it and all that other
kind of stuff yeah or like rubbing their
bodies together like that like that's
what a lot of them describe Z getting
jalous you Zach hears me talk about
[__] hot tubs and [__] rubbing and
[__] shampoo bottles and [__]
bubble bath and [__] [__] Gavin
Friday playing angel in the back
me and Zack in the [__] top of the
damn Sans Hotel down in [__] yeah
spinning that's right the whole hotel
the whole hotel pitous is just spinning
he's getting jealous yeah getting
jealous it's gonna be all right Zach
don't tell don't tell your
man Zach says Jen's gonna be there to
videotape put that [__] up on Mini
fit he said didn't uh Michael Jackson
and Farah faucet die on the same
day or something I vaguely remember that
happening when I was I don't remember
that I don't remember if that happened
or not he died in
2009 what was the date May or I thought
I thought Farah had died before that I
thought so too but I can't really
remember it was really weird because
when I was watching all the stuff about
Michael Jackson it's just kind of like I
thought he died more recently than 2009
because when I was like God it was 2009
that was a long [__] time ago I
didn't realize it was that long ago man
time flies when you getting old Li Zach
said
yeah Tom we can go in the in the hot tub
at the bath house and create a new super
STD along with the other
ones oh my God yeah we'll name it after
you
zitis Zach imuno
deficiency Z imun deficiency Zid yeah Z
oh my God but yeah so uh I don't [__]
know but yeah so that's so that's the
thing so all right now
there a lot obviously I don't know if
like these kids today if they remember
all the crazy [__] story even before
all the molestation [__] came out which
was in
1993 um there was a lot of crazy stories
about Michael Jackson before that
remember when he supposedly like tried
to Bo buy the bones of the Elephant Man
like from the museum or whatever and
they were like no you can't have those
you know what I mean yeah so it's a
museum it's not like a store he probably
wouldn't have paid for a anyway I heard
he bought stuff and returned it a lot
never paid for really I never heard that
that he' go on shopping spre and he'd
buy everything and then and then when it
came time for him to pay they never
would pay and so he'd never even pick it
up he just like to buy things and he
didn't he didn't need them and that well
that's another thing that he would do
with like the kids and like I said it
wasn't just the kids it was their whole
families like he almost like seduced
their whole families which is again is a
very common PDF file thing you're
establishing trust um and I didn't
realize the extent to which he did that
um you know until I watched leaving
Neverland and like started reading about
it I'm like holy crap so it's yeah it's
crazy so he would take these people like
I said he would take them on tour with
him he's like oh we're going to go to
the World Music Awards we're going to go
we're going to go to Paris we're going
to go to Berlin we're going to go
everywhere and then he would take the
whole family mostly the boys but like
and the moms too like he would really
try to like get in good with the moms
and he would take them to a store and be
like just fill up a cart buy whatever
you want you know like you take them to
a toy store or some [__] like that so he
was really good at and and I'm sure that
he would probably frame it as what I'm
you know I'm being nice to them I'm
being generous and stuff like that which
I guess you are to a fault but you're
also bribing the family you're bribing
them is what you're doing I don't really
know if he was self-aware enough to know
that that's what he was doing but that's
what he was doing I think he I think he
figured you know they probably know
what's going on so I'm just going to go
ahead and make it worth their while yeah
maybe yeah that's probably what he was
thinking so I don't know so they won't
they won't ask me any
questions yeah yeah cuz yeah I don't
want to get in trouble if you give them
enough stuff it's like [__] if you're
hanging out with somebody that's got
like all the money and they just buy you
[__] and take you on trips and
everything like that you're going to
overlook a lot of [__] I think you can
flip it around I think most people would
you can flip it around you have your
lawyers run at him and says wait a
minute you're accepting all this money
and offering up your child isn't that
prostitution yeah they can do that yeah
that's another thing so yeah that's
another thing W and I'm going to say
that when we were watching leaving
Neverland the mom like Wade's mom her
name is
Joy um I kind of think she probably knew
what was going or suspected what was
going on she kind of denied knowing what
was going on but I I think there is a
reason that the rest of her family um
they wouldn't talk to her for a long
time yeah because I think she kind of
knew what was going or suspected what
was going on and she just didn't want
you know she didn't want to jump off the
gravy train allegedly yeah I think
that's what it was so it's I and I think
that might have been the case because
like I said if if Michael Jackson didn't
have wasn't famous and didn't have
millions and billions of dollars would
you like I don't have any kids but if
you had a kid everybody I know that had
a kid is like no [__] way would I let
my kid sleep in the same bed as a grown
ass man who I barely know a for like a
month why would you do that and he was
started with that kind of [__] with them
at what six seven yeah I think well Wade
was five when he first met him but I
don't think the uh alleged abuse started
until he was seven yeah it seemed like
he was kind of into him from like about
age 789 until they were about 14 so like
right after they went through puberty or
started to become looking like a
teenager yeah he then he seemed like he
kind of replaced it yeah Bryce Versa
said that documenter documentary was
uncomfortable yeah you saw the way he
said little one yeah and he had like
little nicknames for all of them and
it's like the one guy I think it was
James like he had um Michael Jackson had
like sent him all these
faxes um like they both had had all like
all these faxes and they they would like
talk to them on the he would talk to
them on the phone for like six seven
hours like he would call every single
day yeah what you going to talk to a kid
for seven hours for that's what I mean
it's just like it's where are the women
where are the women or where are the
grown men yeah cuz I think he was
probably gay but like why why where are
the people his own age like why isn't he
going out with people his own age it
just seems like I don't think he saw
himself as gay I think he didn't want to
see himself as gay I think I think he
saw himself as a
child yeah you know what I mean and that
he's fooling around with other little
boys and it's also innocent yeah we
don't really have gender you know yeah
maybe that's what it was yeah I think
it's kind of I mean he certainly had
some really Weir well when you when you
when you see his act and and listen to
his songs he didn't write those songs
you know he had writers right all that
[__] and his portrayal of sexuality is
very much kind of
cartoonish you know he I don't think he
knew much about heterosexuality you know
what I mean these [__] love songs
about women and his dancing and [__] it
looked cool but he was just making a
product you know yeah for for
armies well and it worked it made all
the money yeah and the thing about it
like when I I got to say though I think
the reason why he was such a
success is because in the in the early
80s or the maybe in the mid 80s I
remember when I first saw him he was one
of the first stars that really jumped on
music videos yeah he made music videos
that just were much much better than
everybody else
the first one I remember was Billy Jean
yeah nobody had a video it was like that
he's walking and the [__] ground's
lighting up as he's going what year was
that that was 82 I think and that was
the debut of the moonwalk also yeah when
when that when that video appeared on
MTV it just dominated [__] MTV
because that was the best video that
made up to that time high budget most
music videos are just like you could
shoot one in this room right you know
they didn't
or it was like Blondie Blondie's videos
were just them in [__] abandoned
buildings and stuff wearing trash bags
and
crap Deborah was wearing a trash bag but
I mean they were cool but they weren't
expensive yeah [__] Jackson had
expensive videos it was a brand new
medium and it that those videos caused a
[__] ton of attention in record sales
and he was Quality quality show so when
he went on tour he just killed it you
know so and he was doing that in the
early ' 80s yeah the only other thing
that would been kind of like that would
have been kiss but kiss didn't have
music videos that just a good show it
was like something you see out of Vegas
you know right kiss [__] had sucky
albums and they
[__] man you buy album there might be
one good song on it yeah well but that
album looked cool as [__] and they and
[__] Jean Sims to sell you a lunchbox
you could have a lunch box a belt buckle
it was more about a merchandise and the
way they looked and the shows were big
fire and the music was just like music
was in N it was okay you
know but um Jackson had it all he had
the huge
show
[__] pro dancers and stuff and music
videos and the quality of the of the
writing of the songs was good execution
was real good he just he when he
appeared he was [__] just he
dominated and that really I think helped
him have some staying power over the
years because he built so many fans in
their early part of his
career but look you got to be let's be
honest the the Bad album was pretty good
I liked
it uh when it came out I thought it was
his best album at at to the at that date
I didn't buy it but I think I borrowed
it or or somebody gave me a recording of
it on on I think on tape I would never
buy a Michael Jackson record back would
you know what I mean I was more I was
into metal but for pop music that was
good yeah real
good but as time went on he he kind of
wasn't as great as he was musical
musically wise and he wasn't as
Innovative he wasn't a great innovator
really he's more kind of following the
transs
um if you're talking about creativity
the other and just music quality and
show for africanamerican performance
Prince was better well yeah much better
well like you said Prince was a lot more
Innovative yeah and and I think he was a
lot more musically talented yeah and um
he didn't have this kind of problem
holding him down Prince was a man you
know he's a little guy but he was about
women and real Snappy dressers yeah and
he had he had that [__] he was a
[__] magnet yes and back today you call
him G kind of like gender
nonbinary kind of but back in those days
it was just we called it be a new wave
yeah but we didn't really have a word
for it he was just this sexy little
[__] that was kind of gender
bending and the girls loved him MH I
think he's
53 wearing in big old high heels I think
he's 5 I think he's my height yeah huge
heels and [__] [__] you know and CU
saying I would give it to I would give
it to Prince yeah over Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson just had a really good
show yeah and um music videos were good
were real good yeah but when Prince came
out with his music videos they were
[__] great too the Purple Rain
video Raspberry Beret video [__] all
that [__] was good yeah High Desert said
dur Durant had great videos too yeah I
was going to say between Michael Jackson
and Duran Duran I think that's kind of
what carried MTV through the early years
because well well you know just like
Michael Jackson like Durand Duran spent
some [__] money on their [__]
videos let's go to Sri Lanka and film
like some videos like on a yacht and
[__] like that you know very Lifestyles
of the Rich and Famous yeah but that
kind of weird gender
bending light skinned kind of
africanamerican looking thing you know
Prince and Prince and Michael Jackson
were on on the surface level would seem
real
similar but in terms of artistic quality
no man I I'm going to give it to [__]
Prince yeah there's more substance to
him yeah and OK Boomer lady makes a good
point uh Michael Jackson owed a lot to
Quincy Jones yeah because that was his
producer on all of his good albums um
and I think like his albums weren't as
good when he didn't work with Quincy
Jones anymore so I think yeah I I think
it was mostly the fact that yeah he
could sing and yeah he could dance and
he was really charismatic and you know
um but like I said a lot of it might
have been and the producers and good
songs like The Bu SS buy good songs off
good songwriters and St although you
know that's you know that's okay that
was standard procedure [__] drad dur
bought a lot of songs and they had a lot
of help a lot of people did yeah they
just did that yeah and a producers like
producers are always like right you can
get um the the the original like demos
of things like Grand ran songs like View
to a Kill and [__] uh just other
famous songs and they didn't originally
the demos did didn't sound anything like
the the song that ended up on the on the
record because they worked on them and
they would hire other dudes to come in
and rewrite [__] for them because you
had to they were multi-billion dollar
[__] industry man it was back when
bands [__] powerhouses when it came
to money because it was just records and
radio play there was no Spotify or
Internet you had to if you wanted to
hear that song you had to [__] go
either [__] buy the album the tape or
have somebody burn record the album for
you on a tape yeah and if you liked it
you probably would go see them [__]
live when they came when the tour came
they were going to make money off you it
was they made good money records were
expensive they were $2 back then yeah or
you know a good a good album was about
20 bucks back in the 80s it was [__]
expensive a lot of money yeah it was a
lot of money back then I had to like ask
for him for Christmas and [__] yeah or
like save up yeah like birthday money if
I wanted one record you know yeah it was
kind of with taxes [__] you could
only buy four of them and then you 100
bucks right okay Boomer lady says Prince
was also a Jehovah's
Witness which is uh you wasn't
practicing I'm sure well yeah that's
pretty weird it's like I don't know like
I said you didn't really hear that I
kept forgetting about that Michael
Jackson being one yeah but yeah so uh
Neverland Ranch he built that well he
actually bought the property for it in
1980 8 and uh you know famously I think
he owned it well he still owned it when
he died but after um all of the uh the
police raids where they kind of went
through it and everything like looking
for [__] um he didn't ever go back there
after that because I guess they thought
he thought that it had been diso it was
soiled yeah they came they took pictures
of my penis yeah that was yeah cuz I
think somebody asked like asked earlier
didn't they take pictures well yeah
because some of the um the the kids that
alleged that he had molested them like
had descriptions of what his penis
looked like yeah so of course they had
to like put him in a room and take
pictures of him yeah it's funny he he's
tell he's doing a press they took
pictures of my penis my bottock f it's
[__] funny yeah he looked mortified
but I don't know why he [__] came out
with that well I guess he thought he was
GNA he was just trying to fight it he
just trying to fight yeah and I think
that he was um and they they kind of
went went into this in the video I was
watching earlier about PDF files and
about how a lot of them react when they
are accused of it and they said a lot of
times what they'll do is that they'll
get like super super outraged and like
play the victim yeah yeah like to make
you feel bad for them like this is all
kind of everyone's just out to get me
and all this other kind of stuff which
like I said I'm not saying that some
people weren't out to get him or just
weren't out to like get his money cuz
I'm sure they were yeah but that doesn't
NE
that doesn't necessarily mean that he
wasn't like molesting kids you know what
I mean both of those things could
allegedly allegedly you know Ben the
testimony's there though and It just
fits see that's another thing see Ben
says did Michael Jackson drink alcohol
yes like so according to like according
to everybody like he used to drink he
had a wine seller I think yeah and it's
just and he used to drink wine all the
time and that was kind of one of the
things um that was one of the charges I
think it was from the 2005 trial that um
that he was actually putting wine in
soda cans and giving it to the little
boys so that like their parents wouldn't
know that they were drinking like I
don't know if that's true or not but
that was one of the charges that he was
like kind of getting them drunk you know
what I mean and um I think too that
drinks but the kids must have known they
must have known that it had well yeah
yeah yeah he wasn't trying to fool the
kids he trying to fool the parents he
was just trying to fool the parents like
what it's just our little secret it's
just yeah and he's just like putting
wine in there we're gonna have fun come
on yeah Alison said Jesus Juice he
called it yeah that's right yeah that's
right it s from about Jesus J yeah
that's what he called it he drank his
alcohol from a sippy cup yeah with crazy
straws yeah [__] funny I can I can
actually picture that I can actually
picture that but yeah so okay so let's
talk about like the first kid like this
first allegation this is when all the
[__] first started coming out because
like I said during the 80s dude was
super super famous I mean he was one of
the most famous and still is like one of
the most famous musicians that has ever
lived you know what I mean so in
1993 here's what happened it was early
1993 it was like February and Michael
Jackson's car broke down and got towed
to a garage as as you would called rent
now the owner of the rent Who's name was
David Schwarz called his wife up her
name was June and said oh my God Michael
Jackson just came to my garage because
his car broke down um you got to come
down here and meet him and so she
brought her son like from a previous
marriage whose name is Jordan Chandler
now Jordan's dad whose name was Evan
Chandler was a dentist and he was like
kind of like dentist to the Stars like
he did a lot of celebrities and stuff
and he's also a screenwriter if you
remember that movie The Mel um Mel
Brooks movie Robin Hood Men and tights
yeah like he wrote the screenplay for
that so um because you can't just be a
dentist in Hollywood you also have to be
a screenwriter too apparently so um
so Michael Jackson meets this Jordan kid
and apparently becomes quite enamored
with him and this is something that's
very common and like I said if you watch
Leaving Neverland this is kind of the
same thing that happened with the with
those two kids in
there what he would do he would befriend
the boy and then he would like pretty
much ingratiate himself like into their
entire family like he would either
invite the whole family to Neverland
where they would stay for like all
weekend or they would stay like for a
few weeks at a time or whatever or he
would go and stay at their houses which
I thought was very weird cuz a lot of
them were just regular ass like middle
class Suburban families and he would
just go and stay at their house like he
would go have dinner with them yeah and
he would just kind of like he's like the
most famous pop star in the world and
he's just like I'm just going to hang
out with these [__] nobody's which
you know what I mean which is you know
not nobody's but just like regular ass
people it's just like a weird thing for
a celebrity to be doing is what the
thing is though Michael Jackson in a way
was a regular ass person though too I
guess because he didn't really I don't
think he had much contact with other
celebrities he was just he was very much
in his own little world yeah yeah
surrounded by a bunch of people who were
yes men that worked for him and PR
people and he had a whole he was
shielded by a [__] Entourage but he
he wasn't a normal person yeah he didn't
live like a normal person um but he was
still that kid struggling with his
family you know what I mean trying to
make it big the only difference is he
had money yeah he was free for free of
them now he had a palace and he had
money yeah and I guess and I do feel bad
like I said much you right well and you
know I do feel bad that he apparently
had like an abusive childhood he didn't
really have a childhood I mean he was
working from the time he was what five
or six years old yeah um and so he
didn't really get to have a normal life
so I get it like I get why he spent his
entire adulthood seemingly trying to
recapture a childhood that he felt was
denied to him I suppose um yeah
something went down in that childhood he
got fixated sexually at a certain yeah
and and that's pretty common too like um
all that stuff that I was watching about
PDF files they said that is a very
common thing to happen for like um the
person to like stop maturing at a
certain age so it's like they get older
and older but they still want to hang
out with you know 10y old or whatever
even though they're like 25 now yeah
because that's the level that they're at
and that's kind of like um there's a
phrase for it but I can't remember what
it was but um but yeah Arrested
Development yeah that's exactly what it
is so I kind of feel like that's what
his situation was and then he tells the
kids you know oh don't talk to them
they're ignorant they don't understand
yeah that's exactly what he would say
and a lot of yeah he seemed very like I
said and I don't know if he was
self-aware enough to know that he was
cuz some people are just straight up
predators and they're doing this [__]
like with full awareness of how they're
manipulating people and stuff I don't
know if he was aware if that's what he
was doing or if he was I think he was
able to justify it to himself cuz like I
said I don't think that he thought
because he had absolutely no problem at
all telling people just openly on many
occasions that he slept in bed with
children yeah like and multiple like
interviewers were like well don't you
think that's inappropriate or you know
isn't that weird you're just ignorant
you're ignorant like it's beautiful yeah
yeah right yeah he's like we're just
hanging out and having sharing
somebody's bed is like the best is the
most loving thing you can do like [__]
like that like he would say stuff like
that and the fact that he wasn't even
hiding it yeah and like just trying to
make everybody else oh everybody else
just has dirty minds yeah and I'm just
like I I I don't think that's the case I
I think I think it's weird I think it's
weird behavior and
99.999% people in the world also think
it's weird Behavior he didn't he because
he wasn't a normal person and he was
being shielded by bunch of PR people and
[__] handlers and stuff and I don't I
don't think he knew how normal people
thought yeah and it probably wouldn't
have mattered because he just said well
they're ignorant so it doesn't matter
what they think yeah and he he saw
himself as a good guy and that he loved
these dudes these little kids and these
kids loved him and and uh he thought it
was okay because they were at his level
or he believed that they were kind of
like at his level in some weird way yeah
I really do think that he didn't think
he was hurting them like he would not
have thought it was abuse he would not
have thought even though he was
absolutely manipulating them into by the
witness's testimony they said that they
didn't think they were being hurt either
until they got older and then they
realized what was going on right well
because they were so they said it happen
one dude said that he realized that he
had [__] been [__] over when he had
kids and he was like thinking this is
about the age I was hanging out with
Michael Jackson he goes that
[__] because and they're like I
would never let my kid hang out with
somebody like he' realize wait a minute
that was me you know yeah yeah and that
yeah that was like really a telling
moment that he said he's like he he kind
of knew it was abused like later like
when he got older but he's like it
really hit home for him when he had when
he had kids and he realized like he's
like especially when my son got to the
same age as I was when I was hanging out
and he was just like man if somebody
came to me now and said hey I'm going to
take your and like sleep with them at
the same he I he's like i' knock him the
[__] out you're at a huge disadvantage
at seven versus an adult well yeah
mentally you're huge dis just [__]
night and day I mean
[__] I can remember being 18 and 19 and
not being able to grasp things that uh
people in their 30s could easily grasp
I'd reject it no that can't be oh yeah
yeah that's the way it really is yeah uh
you know [__] I didn't really felt I
didn't really feel like I understood the
game I thought I understood the game at
about 25 but then when I hit 30 I
realized I didn't know what the [__] I
was talking about at 25 I didn't I don't
think I really became who I am until
about
30 after the [__] service and
everything yeah yeah about now late 20s
maybe 27 probably yeah around that
time it just the male brain doesn't
develop at the same speed as the female
brain this is
[__] a given I've seen that I've seen
the data on it it's uh certain parts of
the brain mature faster than the others
in males in males uh in females it's a
lot of frontal lobe
development just put
a put a put a 16-year-old boy next to a
16-year- old girl that girl will [__]
outperform him
mentally yeah with with people yeah well
because a 16-year-old boy his entire
brain is just boobs yeah yeah
pretty primitive yeah that's what I mean
I mean you know not entirely I guess but
um yeah they're talking about his kids
yeah actually Michael Jackson had three
kids with um Debbie row his second wife
now it's alleged he didn't father them
they're not his that they're not his
kids he had a sperm donor which is
really weird cuz I saw an interview with
the guy who was the sperm donor I think
on one of the kids he was he's he's kind
of famous like I'd seen him before but I
can't think of what his name is and he
was on there and I think Matt low was
interviewing him and he said well if he'
wanted kids and he couldn't perform
sexually because that's what they were
assuming like with a woman um they're
like well couldn't he just like jerk off
into a cup and artificial ination right
so it's like why did he need another
dude's sperm he wanted kids that he
could could could have yeah so I so I'm
not really sure like some I there has
been some speculation that he wanted
white kids yeah and he was afraid that
if he gave his sperm then they would
turn out black and he wouldn't be happy
about that of course so I don't know if
that's true or not but that is one
speculation it's like why he didn't use
his own semen well he wanted to be white
he wanted his kids to be white right
yeah so the kids are not biologically
related to him no no they they're
Scandinavian as [__] last time look like
blond haired
blueeyed ice blue eyes and [__] they're
designer
babies yeah yeah and that and the weird
thing about that too like Debbie Rose
she was like the she was like the
assistant of
his uh somebody that worked for him yeah
like his lawyer no I I don't know I have
it in my notes somewhere but somebody
somebody that worked for him like she
was their assistant or the something and
that's how they hooked up but they were
married for three years but it's just
like I don't think they ever had sex I
don't think he ever had sex with Lisa
Marie either because he married her like
right after like it was not quite a year
after like the first sexual abuse
allegations came out and she had only
been divorced from her husband for like
3 weeks when she married him Lisa Marie
was real vague about what happened with
that marriage all all she did was
basically when I remember she was on uh
the Howard Stern Show as a guest one
time Howard Stern had asked this is back
when Howard Stern was relevant all right
[__] and she just went oh that
[__] basically
she I don't want to talk about that I
think she might have been under um kind
of like a gag order maybe there's
probably some kind of illegal thing that
she [__] signed with him yeah like a
non-disclosure kind agreement because
she couldn't talk about him she didn't
want she refused to talk about him so I
was thinking man he must have had her
legally wrapped up I think he just hired
her to help him get out of those
allegations in exchange for helping her
music career yeah he probably said I
I'll get I'll get right behind you music
career you'll be famous yeah yeah pipe
dream Lisa Marie would never be famous
for
music well and I did see like a clip of
an interview with her where she was
saying that she implied that um that
Michael Jackson knew Debbie row who
would become his second wife later on um
a long time ago you know what I mean and
she and Lisa Marie said
that that Michael Jackson allegedly said
to her that it's like oh if you don't
marry me then I'll just get Debbie to do
it you know what I mean cuz I guess he
needed like a front because he was thank
you very much Bryce that's awesome I
think Michael was guilty as hell uh yeah
I kind of suspect he was as well
convenient that all the boys he was
friends with were good-look yeah they
kind of went into that on uh this other
documentary I was watching where it's
like all the kids were were super cute
yeah and not all of them were white some
of them were mix race but yeah Victor
says blanket and Prince do not look
white they definitely look mixed dark
hair eyes and complexion so yeah I don't
I don't know seen yeah like I said I've
only seen them when they were younger
and I don't even remember what they look
like I thought one of them was just
definitely just like Scandinavian
looking yeah maybe from what I saw been
a long time that was a long time ago
because I think the guy that was talking
like that he because uh that was one of
the sperm donors or so he said he was a
white dude but that might have just been
the other one you know what I mean cuz
he had like I said he had three kids
yeah yeah ok Boomer lady said the kids
would get his original nose
yeah yeah that's maybe that's what he
was afraid of he didn't want those
features yeah because he had a lot of
self-hatred about it because he'd always
been kind of like he I saw and I
actually did kind of feel bad for him
for a second or for little him you know
what I mean yeah um um hold on I wanted
to say um uh I just wanted to uh plug
the super thanks button if you're
listening to the channel uh recorded uh
and you and you want to give us a a tip
you you can do it through super thanks
it is activated and uh thanks Bryce for
the first Super Chat of the evening
thank you very much thank you very much
looking that that helps out because we
didn't mix [__] on stream mate
today pimping ourselves out it was slow
as [__] today yeah I know starting to
get worried but uh but yeah what are you
gonna do it's just a numbers game what
are you GNA do you just got to sit there
and roll with it yeah but um now I
forgot what I was going to say uh winter
fell forever said being a totally
unashamedly armchair psychoanalyst here
Jackson seemed to have a lot of
self-hatred issues regarding probably to
his father's abuse when being a very
young child oh yeah definitely and he I
I was watching an interview with him and
he
remembered um an event from his
childhood well I guess when he was like
a little bit older he's like so he was
out with all his brothers you know and
the Jackson 5 were very very famous at
this time but he had grown up a little
bit she like and this person came up
that was like a fan it's like oh my my
God the Jackson 5 you know what I mean
and she's like looking at all of them
he's like where's little Michael where's
little Michael and they said oh he's
over there and he had grown up some and
the woman went uh what happened to him
like cuz he got older you know what I
mean like he wasn't cute anymore right
and um so apparently that affected him a
lot and like I said his dad used to like
[__] with him about his nose and all
that other kind of [__] too so you know
um yeah hi Des said I read rumors that
MJ's father called him uh and [__] yeah I
don't want to say that but uh and other
names regularly yeah I'd heard that as
well I'd heard that as well um so yeah
his dad really didn't seem like a nice
person yeah he was ignorant yeah it's
you know and like I said that in no way
excuses um anything yeah but uh might
part of the problem he definitely when
he got his hands on his on money I don't
think he want he was trying to re reboot
his whole life and his whole self he
changed the way he looked uh I don't
think he wanted really anything to do
with his family he probably paid them
off to try to get rid of a lot of them I
think he I think he uh was on okay terms
with Janet though I think I think um for
a little while although Latoya she came
out and said that she thought he that he
was a p PDF file but then later on she
recanted that and said oh my abusive
husband like he was abusive like he'd
been arrested for it and stuff he made
me say that and then I'm just sitting
there going why would he make you say
that but I don't know I don't know if
true or not but she recanted it later
but I don't really know cuz I think they
kind of the family kind of disowned her
for a little while yeah like after she
said that she thought that he
was that thought that she was that he
was a PDF file yeah so I actually
thought Janet was okay I thought her
music was okay when it came out it just
more pop music it did sound like Michael
Jackson music a little bit though well
yeah kind of I mean they're all in the
same family so I mean obviously yeah
yeah yeah American Military 100 said uh
Michael Jackson was made fun of by his
brothers and father for having a ball
pepper nose or B pepper bell pepper I'm
not sure a bell pepper nose I guess cuz
it was wide yeah and then he also said
he was very close with LaToya they were
the closest of all the siblings Latoya
said that she had seen like payoff
checks that he was given to like the
kids and stuff Bryce said it's weird
because Michael was actually goodlooking
a good-looking guy before his surgeries
he was um you know when yeah he looked a
little awkward when he was a teenager
but a lot of people look awkward when he
teenager whatever did you know
celebrities get little tweaks they just
do cuz they can afford them I would have
kept him I would have kept it right
about Thriller that looked that would
have kept it like that bad I thought he
looked fake he yeah he started going a
little bit too I was like come on man
and then he just started looking you
like a Disney you look like a Disney
princess not not a real Disney but a
drawing of a Disney princess yeah he
started to look like not like a person
anymore like he started to look like a
weird yeah simulacrum of a person yeah
you know cuz of so cuz they were doing
so much weird [__] to his yeah and then
they were airbrushing all the photos you
weren't sure exactly what he look
like was looking at seeing one I cover
that bad album and I was just going like
I love those boots though I was going
those some badass [__] boots I was
like where did he get those boots and
really I'm bounced to the modern Normie
[__] um the the Normie back in those
days probably even today wouldn't know
that Michael Jackson ripped those boots
and a lot of the lot of that outfit from
that album
ripped it off from The Goth scene yeah
yeah especially those boots yeah those
goth [__] Goths are wearing it those are
very [__] boots they were custom made to
him but that's what that's what that's
what inspired him yeah basically tall
pixie boots of buckles going up the
sides kind of like a motorcycle
Motocross boot really or Winkle Pickers
that's what to call them the idea was
based upon motorcycle group boots though
yeah Ben said there were rumors that
Latoya was Michael Jackson and drag yeah
I remember hearing all
that well she also got most of her nose
shaved off so you know I can see how
they were saying that yeah said they
were never seeing
together yeah I've heard that too I
don't know if that's the case but they
uh she she's not as she was not as pale
as them though but her nose looked as
[__] up but you know we still got a
lot of ground to cover don't we we do
yeah but I'm just kind of going through
like you know what I mean because we
talked about a lot of it already well
yeah that's what I mean so I'm just kind
of like jumping around but I do have
kind of like all these notes and stuff
so yeah so this so this first kid this
is how this happened so Michael
Jackson's car breaks down the guy that
owns the garage calls his wife and's
like holy [__] Michael Jackson's here he
Super Famous like come down here and
meet him and she brought the kid
Jordan now so Michael Jackson and Jordan
start to become buddies like I said and
this is a very common this is what
happened to like a lot of these kids and
so Michael Jackson starts hanging out
with this whole entire family so Michael
invited Jordan J Jordan's stepsister and
his mom to Neverland Ranch and they
would come there like every weekend he
also took them to Florida he took him to
Las Vegas like he took them on all these
trips and stuff so at this point Evan
who's the dad like I said the mom has
already has remarried so they're like
separated right they're divorced but
Evan um the dad he is like supposed to
see the kid on weekends but obviously
the kid is like no I want to go to
Neverland and hang out with the famous
person and instead of seeing my dumbass
dad but then it seemed like Evan told
the kid hey you should spend more time
with Michael Jackson and then says to
Michael you should build an extension on
Neverland so we can live there you know
yeah and so I guess he was going to do
it cuz he went and like pulled the per
and tried to get permits and everything
like that but they couldn't get a permit
so then Evan says well why don't you buy
buy us a house then and I guess so I
guess he did so like I said that was the
same month that um that they went to the
World Music Awards in Monaco and that
was where like I said I saw that real
uncomfortable clip of like this
13-year-old boy like sitting in Michael
Jackson's lap and it looks like really
really weird um Evan apparently got mad
about this because he wanted to go to
Monaco like he's the dad right um you
know so uh so he got mad and he starts
getting uh all upset about it now at
this point Evan said he was starting to
suspect that Michael Jackson was doing
something with his son he's like because
he would see them and he's like he never
saw them doing
anything inappropriate necessarily but
he's like they were always in the room
like for a long time he's like he would
see them in bed together even though
they had clothes on and [__] like that
so but he started to think something
fishy was up now in July of that year he
calls up um or like the the stepdad
Jordan's stepdad calls up Evan his real
dad and they're talking about what do
you think is going on with this Michael
Jackson situation now uh David Schwarz
who was the stepdad he was recording
this conversation this is this is very
It's All Over YouTube like you can uh
find this conversation and uh apparently
Evan Chandler on this phone call is very
very hostile he calls Michael Jackson
evil and he said uh that he had hired a
lawyer the nastiest son of a [__] I
could find um and said he said once I
make that phone call this guy is going
to destroy everybody in sight in any
devious nasty cruel way that he can do
it I've given him full authority to do
that if I go through with this I win big
time there's no way I lose I will get
everything I want and they will be
destroyed forever Michael's career will
be over this man is going to be
humiliated beyond belief he will not
believe what is going to happen to him
Beyond his worst nightmares he will not
sell one more record which that wasn't
how that turned out but so as you can
imagine this recording was like a big uh
thing for the defense like when this you
know when they were like talking about
it going to trial and everything
although I don't think this actually
went to trial because Michael Jackson
paid them off um you know what I mean
which doesn't necessarily imply anything
but you know I'm just saying that he
like they came to a settlement now the
thing about this so Evan seems to be
saying that he's going to just Sue
Michael Jackson back to the Stone Age
presumably because of the allegation but
he's just trying to get money because at
this point David Schwarz the stepdad
says well how with that help Jordy
Jordan and the dad says that's
irrelevant to me like he didn't really
seem to care that much about the kid I
guess um and then he said the bottom
line is yes his mother is harming him
and Michael is harming him I can prove
that and I will prove that it cost me
tens of thousands of dollars to get the
information I got and you know I don't
don't have that kind of money I'm
willing to go down financially
so it so happened that a month after
that Chandler who remember as I
mentioned was a dentist he was pulling
one of Jordan's teeth and he had him
under the you know the anesthetic or the
sedative or whatever and he apparently
when he had him under he asked if
Michael Jackson had molested him and the
boy said that he had so at this point
Evan Chandler goes to Michael Jackson's
lawyers and asks for $20 million and
said or I'm going to take you to court
like for child Mo
molestation Michael Jackson says no way
and then um a couple weeks later though
his lawyers Michael Jackson's lawyers
come back and go tell you what we'll
give you a million dollars and Evan
Chandler said no um how about 15 million
so then Michael Jackson said no again
and said oh well now I'm just going to
give you 350,000 and then Evan Chandler
said absolutely not um he also there
were stories going around too that he
was trying to get a Film Production deal
because remember I said he was a
screenwriter so he was um trying to get
that as well but the thing about it and
I think that something that a lot of
people use
to to kind of like argue Michael
Jackson's innocence is that you know if
all of these people that said that they
knew this stuff was going on like cuz
because some of his um the staff that
worked at Neverland like maids and
drivers and things like that allegedly
said that they saw oh I saw Michael
Jackson like naked in the shower with a
boy like some of them you know the maid
said like I saw their like their
underwear like together on the floor and
like all this other kind of stuff or
like they were naked in the hot tub or
something and like one of the maids I
think like even quit over it but but
none of them went to the cops though and
a lot of people are just kind of like
Well if you really thought something bad
was going on with these kids why didn't
you go to the cops and a couple of them
actually went to like you know tabloid
TV shows like hard copy and [__] like
that and like made thousands of dollars
telling that story so people do try to
discredit them that way um which I which
I get had she gone to the cops nothing
would have happened yeah the cops
there's no complaint right showed up
went you is he molesting you and the kid
would have go no and they okay we got to
go bye-bye that's what would happen and
maybe and one of the people said that
they because they said well why didn't
you go to the cops if you knew this was
going on he's like well I didn't think
they would believe me yeah well they
wouldn't
care there has to be a complaint I mean
maybe not cuz they have to prove it yeah
and if they don't have the kid as a
witness yeah to give the testimony it'll
never happen then it'll never happen
it's it's not going to be look we're
going to look man we're going to have to
do blood tests on everybody here we're
going to make see make we're going to
[__] make sure he isn't diddling
anybody you know what I mean the kids
are going there oh he ain't de in nobody
you know oh we arrest them all you know
[__] separate them ain't gonna happen
right it ain't going happen there's got
to be a
complaint but that's the thing and and
particularly something like this like
any kind of like sexual abuse or
particularly child sexual abuse it's
very difficult to prove just by its very
nature got to be a complaint from the
kid or the parents of the kid right and
even can't be the M I think he's
diddling them kids they like yeah
they're not complaining though you got
to be able to prove it you know yeah
that's the thing so so yeah I can say
yeah it was probably pretty shitty that
like she got $20,000 from hard copy or
whatever the [__] like for selling her
story CH Ching but yeah well everybody
got to cash in somehow cash in she she
didn't any part of it she left yeah
that's all she could do she might as
well cash out yeah damage his reputation
that's it help damage his reputation I
mean it did look we're still talking
about it now you know I don't have any
proof I can't say it you know allegedly
you know BL G to cover cover my own
ass I think he did it I think he did it
based on the testimony I can't prove it
yeah you know I'm not saying he did do
it I'm saying I think he did it yeah I'm
kind of likely in that way too to be
honest it's just there's just too much
when I heard those boys talking about
the things that they did and the
patterns and of of behavior I'm going
like yeah this is a dude running to
Harum and the thing about it like even
before um you know uh before uh Wade and
James and stuff like that who the the
two guys are on leaving Neverland like
this kid Jordan the first one that came
out with and I don't even know if this
was like the first kid that he did this
to this is just the first one that like
that reported it I guess um when they
interviewed him um he this the stuff
that he said that Michael Jackson did
was very similar to what the other what
the what the two of them said on that
documentary like almost exactly the same
like the same kind of patterns the same
little nicknames that he had like this
just the same
situation the just the whole situation
was very very similar yeah and um yeah I
he he was being a play booy yeah and it
was just kind of like Jordan said there
because I saw like some interviews where
the cops were interviewing him and um
you know and he was like a tween or like
a teenager at this point and he said
that um and and this is something that
the other kid said too that it's like
you know he would like kind of put his
hand like over their crotch like with
the pants on but then like reach in
there but he was always trying to tell
them it's like you know like trying to
teach them how to masturbate or you know
or I can do it for you or something like
that like it was always that kind of
[__] so asking asking if he could kiss
it like that kind of thing that like a
couple of them like reported that as
well so it just seemed like a pattern of
behavior yeah and what they said kind of
Lin up and it did kind of line up with
other like stuff that PDF files would do
like this kind of PDF file that um where
they're kind of just trying to groom you
or like manipulate you into doing stuff
and and and not you know not strong
arming or not forcing or anything like
that you're just trying to get you to
like be into it like cuz it's okay and
he he's kind of got his little Herm on a
conveyor belt they're ranging from about
seven up to about 14 and there as one
ages out he's getting new ones about
seven yeah so he's got his little harm
had that been a straight
guy in 33 with all that money
he'd probably have six seven girlfriends
you know yeah ranging from Barely Legal
up to like 40y old super cougar and he'd
be [__] running them on a conveyor
belt too aging them out you know yeah
later on he's 50 he doesn't it's not
quite the same Haram and the 19y old
that he had is now you know whatever 30
something you know that's what he was
doing which I was like I immediately
recognized it as male Behavior yeah so
I'm like yeah that's what he's doing the
so the claims are
very
um
believable very believable I mean it
does it does seem very plausible to me
it's just that his targets
were males at a certain age range that
are underage yeah that's but he's doing
what a straight guy does to older women
basically and like I said it really
seemed like
he these seemed like romances like and
he seemed to see them that way yeah yeah
like he would write them love letters
they would walk around holding hands and
cuddling all the time same thing with a
dude that's 33 and his he loves all that
all those women loves them all equally
yeah until he's not interested anymore
yeah you know and that might be you know
for various reasons they they get sick
of the damn being a part of a Herm and
they find a a man that can afford them
that kind of deal you know that kind
that kind of [__] but yeah they're doing
that too
so yeah so in in this case um it does
seem like the mom didn't think anything
was going on at first but then she like
kind of decided like oh maybe something
is going on like later on um now they
searched they did a search of Neverland
Branch um and they questioned a bunch of
kids who had spent a lot of time with
Michael Jackson all of them what read
what Allison said the bot the bottom one
oh his screen name would be Billy Jean
7214 yeah 7 to 14 7 to
14 oh my God that's a good one that is a
good one that is a good one yeah that
was his age range let go I probably need
some
ice my ice all melted yeah but yeah so a
lot of kids said that you know that he
had never done anything to them and
stuff like that but like I said the
thing about it and this has been brought
up on a couple of different
documentaries too it's that after 1993
when this allegation came out and it was
just like a huge thing and it was like
on all the news and it really kind of
like Abyss merched his
reputation you would think that he would
maybe um
like back off on the whole hanging out
with little kids and like holding hands
with them and taking kids on tour with
him and [__] like that kind of thing
just you know Ju Just because
to avoid any appearance of impropriety I
guess but the fact that he didn't do
that and he just kept on doing the same
[__] anyway and then like I said ended
up going to trial again in 2005 when
they were when they were different kids
making different allegations I just kind
of feel like I think that just goes to
show how he really didn't think I really
don't think that he thought he was doing
anything wrong necessarily like I I'm
not saying that I think he knew it was
wrong because he's like oh we'd get in
big trouble and go to jail if your mom
caught us like cuz some of the kids said
that he told them that
but I don't know he just didn't really
seem to see it as a big deal or he
didn't really seem to see it as a bad
thing it didn't seem like to me which is
messed up I mean he just seemed to think
it was okay well like I said he did know
that he would go to jail if he got
caught I mean he did know that because
some of the kids said that so I don't
know so so yeah he sees himself as a
good guy he doesn't see this as anything
wrong that's what I'm saying right he
loves these kids until he's sick of yeah
until they break up you just don't
understand you're ignorant yeah and
that's the thing and I wanted to bring
this up because Ben pointed out pointed
this out it said some of the kids
testimony has been contradicted it's
like one kid on Finding Neverland I
think this was Wade uh claimed he was
molested at that train station except it
hadn't been built at the time yeah I had
heard that allegation um because I don't
think the train station at Neverland was
built until he was 15 or 16 and I think
that he didn't see Michael Jackson
anymore after he was 14 but I'm not
really sure I'm not really sure if he's
I don't know like I listening to them
talk it just really doesn't seem like
they're making the stuff up and it's
like maybe they knew him too well well
and the thing about it is maybe they
just kind of got timelines confused or
something like that like it happens like
I don't I don't know yeah memory isn't
all that real yeah so so I don't really
know if that completely discounts it
that is that is kind of like a ding
against the story because yeah that
wasn't there and another thing though is
that just because okay we were talking
about some of the celebrities like mly
caulin and [__] some of these I don't
I can't say that dude's name [__]
Cory Feldman yeah Cory Feldman
um just because they weren't molested
doing those were celebrities he might
have been attracted to them he might
have been afraid of them because they
had enough money to defend themselves
they harder to bribe those
families so
he probably didn't do anything with him
yeah that well see that's what we were
talking about before because like I said
mcau culan has always been like a big
champion of Michael Jackson said you
know he hung out with him a lot like
when he you know when home alone came
out and he was real getting real famous
and he's just like oh you know he never
did anything to me we just hung out in
his bedroom played video games and all
that kind of stuff which that very well
may be the case yeah but that doesn't
mean that he didn't do it to other
people like you said perhaps because
mcau culin was famous was like a big
star and like had more eyes on him yeah
maybe it would it was easier for him to
go after kids that were not as well
known probably didn't see M mcau what's
his name mcau c m yeah mcau that's not
even a [__] real name come
on you know if you don't have a name
like Bob or [__] Pete and [__] I'm
not
remember that's not a real name that's
some Hollywood okay just cuz that
kid didn't get the dick didn't mean that
[__] he didn't you know he didn't
want to give it to him it's just he was
he had protection yeah you know what I
mean
so Mike probably had a crush on him but
considered him unattainable yeah kind of
like you're dating a girl or something
you like her but you know you can't get
it it's GNA be something like that yeah
or he got it it but it was true love and
he's gonna [__] back you me I Ain I
ain't G to give you up Michael not till
I die kind well like I said it might
have been because yeah and it could be
like mcau culan he had a lot of problems
also when he was growing up I mean it's
it's difficult like being a child star
like [__] you up really really bad
yeah and then saying that Michael
Jackson [__] you [__] you would put
you [__] your career up if you're famous
too so you can't [__] say anything
well in in a way that's kind of what
that was one of the reasons um that you
know Wade one of the guys on leaving
Neverland that was one of the reasons
that he really didn't want to say
anything was because I mean he's quite
famous like in his own he's a
choreographer and he worked with like in
sync and Britney Spears and stuff like
that and he ended up moving to the
United States when he was a kid because
of Michael Jackson because he was just
lived in Australia and he was a huge
Michael Jackson fan like when he was
five and he learned to dance like him
and he won a dance competition and the
prize was you got to meet Michael
Jackson that's how we met him yeah and
he danced so cool Michael Jackson's like
oh you should come to la like come on
tour with me like he put him up on stage
like in his shows and everything like
that scoop you right up scoop you right
up yeah and so like he moved most of the
family he moved most of the family to
California smooth how you bet Michael
came up with that competition I'm want
to find who can all maybe he did who can
dance like me the best I'm G to see if
he's hot oh yeah he's hot you comeing
with me pack up your whole family just
like Willy Wonka yeah I mean yeah it's
weird I mean when you think about it
like I said and and I think that his mom
in particular a dance partner yeah his
mom in particular like she's interviewed
quite extensively like on this
documentary too and I kind of felt bad
for her but then in another way I was
just kind of like I don't yeah I was
like yeah it's like you picked up your
whole like she seems to regret it now
but he got a career out of it he did
yeah and like I said he did really well
for himself and he seems you know okay
now like he got married he's got a kid
and everything like that but it's just
kind of like
um it's just so weird and she said like
even at the time like her she didn't it
wasn't even the whole family cuz I think
she was still married to her husband but
they left the [__] husband back in
Australia yeah he's like what the [__]
are you going with did he kill himself
later I don't know like several years
later I think he did I think he
committed suicide many years later but
um I don't know if it was just because
of that it might have been like some
other things too but she basically she
took Wade and the
sister and took off and went to and she
said said that it was her dad or her
father-in-law or something like that was
at the airport and said have you lost
your mind yeah like you're just
uprooting your whole entire family and
you go there and but they were with him
Michael Jackson all the time they were
like they stayed in Neverland for like
months at a time yeah t brings up
something brings up a good point he says
well Ted Bundy didn't kill every woman
that he met ex well yeah that's what I
mean so it's just kind of like you know
I'm not saying that like all the kids
that said oh he never molested me I'm
not saying they're lying yeah I'm just
saying maybe he didn't I mean he's had a
bunch of kids around all the time like I
said mostly boys he didn't really seem
to seem to [__] with girls um you know
what I mean like he
didn't he didn't really he had friend he
had friends that were grown women like
he was friends with you know Elizabeth
Taylor famously and I think he was
friends with Brook Shields for a while
[__] like that so so they hung out but
it's just kind of like so he did have
his Champions yeah because you know
Elizabeth Taylor always went to bat for
him and stuff like that but it just
seems liketh T was a [__] hag well yeah
yeah I mean it must be said nothing
wrong with [__] hacks it's just what she
but yeah she she definitely was yeah but
um but yeah so so I kind of feel
like and and like I said it's crazy that
he was just so open
about just he wanted to hang out with
kids he didn't really hang out with
grown-ups all that much like there's all
this footage of him like running around
Neverland Ranch like you know playing
with bubbles and all this other kind of
stuff and there's just these kids and
it's almost always boys almost always
boys and they said that he would have
like all these kids up on stage at his
shows and I was kind of looking too cuz
I was just kind of like how many of them
are girls and it's just like there'd be
like one token girl but it's like it was
pretty much all Bo yeah put one girl put
her over there on the end yeah yeah so I
don't have to look at her I guess he
really didn't seem to have much time for
girls at all of any age Allison asked us
to explain bubbles the chimp yeah what
was that about I mean bubbles the chimp
was just possession it's a
childlike it's like okay I think I think
I think [__] um oh she wants to know
if he had sex with bubbles no I don't
think so I think no I think bubbles po
bubbles I think bubbles was kind of like
the prototype for [__] blanket okay
yeah it's kind of like having a child it
wasn't quite good enough the child that
could tear your arms off yeah they grow
up and they get mean and they can't talk
you know so I think got bored with
bubbles I don't know what happened to
Bubbles probably sold bubbles yeah
whatever did happen to Bubbles did he
just like sell them to sold Bubbles and
then um s him to [__] picture said
heal he just blew
bubbles bub that's a good one oh my God
and he decided he was going to have
children of his own ah with through SP
sperm donors and and paid women and some
people have speculated and like like I
said this is alleged and I don't know if
this is the case or not but cele are
freaks man he the freak of the when when
they I think this was during the 2005
allegations they were talking about
taking his kids away because they didn't
know like if he was doing something to
them too I mean they deny it but you
know and there's I I don't know if
there's any reason to think that he did
anything to his own kids but I don't
think so but yeah I I never really heard
anything like that probably not yeah he
probably wanted to have the experience
of having children he was getting older
by that point yeah I think he died at
what 50 was he was when he died yeah
yeah so which he died older than I
thought he did I thought he died in his
30s or 40s I thought he died 40s yeah he
was 50 50 yeah yep and does anybody know
what he looked like at time of death I
don't think they really well no yeah
they did because he wasn't like
reclusive or anything he was actually
the day before he died he was rehearsing
for he was going to do like a big
comeback tour okay and he was at the
rehearsal and they said he was he seemed
totally fine okay so he looked the same
as he did yeah
probably or less he L the same he did in
his 30s and they said when he died like
the autopsy said that he was actually
like pretty healthy okay but the thing
about it like I said we might get into
that like a little bit later but I mean
he died it was essentially like a drug
overdose well he was um the doctors were
always prescribing him these really
because he had insomnia and so they were
always like he got addicted to
painkillers at one point too I wouldn't
be able to sleep at night either if I
was [__] do sh well yeah you got a
point there juggling all these [__]
boy toys [__]
[__] could come crashing down at any
moment they're all so ignorant yeah yeah
so he's just like keeping them awake so
he had to keep taking more and more
powerful ex sedatives to get him to
sleep evidently so the doctor that ended
up getting uh convicted of like
involuntary manslaughter like I think he
did three years or he got a four-year
sentence but I don't think he served at
all but um they're saying bubbles went
to his Zoo yeah that's what I figur
because they bubbles bit Michael bubbles
knew what was
up you never touch me again
[Laughter]
[__] well at least he didn't at least
he didn't bubbles didn't eat his face
off like the although maybe Michael
Jackson would have like that he's like
oh I can start over clean sleep yeah but
we're terrible you take some off my ass
here and put
on it's smoo her skin
here it'll never grow razor
stubble High Desert said bubbles died
normally a couple of years ago okay yeah
I was I was like he's got to be dead by
now but I'm not I don't remember what
the life expectancy for a chimpanzee is
Victor says y'all should do a show on
Richard Simmons is he a recluse because
he got fat is he being held against his
will I need to know yeah I didn't even
know that that was the thing like he
disappeared oh man Richard Simmons First
of all he was a fake Fitness expert okay
his job was to make fat women feel
better uh fat old women at home to make
them feel better and cuz
he didn't really do much working out nah
he did some [__] you know I moving
his arms and [__] flapping his wings
which I guess is better than sitting on
your ass but still not much better not
much better and then he would [__]
eat eat and [__] and then get on the
show and cry about how about how much
they're Abus hurt and fat women and how
hard it is to be a fat woman
so older fat women could could you know
this is a time when Tel evangelist did
well yeah he was kind of like a t kind
of the same grift as a tel evangelist a
little bit yeah going after kind of like
vulnerable lonely middle-aged women
right I would say he's okay I'm GNA
[__] put it in modern terms he was
the prototype to the fat acceptance
movement it's okay if you're fat do this
and that no you're fat you're fat lose
weight but you're not going to lose your
weight [__] Richard Simmons way you
got to
[__] cut the [__] diet down make
sure the hormones are straight and lift
you'll lose a lot of weight you lose a
lot of
fat aerobic is not that good at it
especially when you're
older Allison said I'd watch a Richard
Simmons podcast I'm okay I'm gonna write
that down because that is actually a
good idea Richard Simmons and yeah well
Victor said yeah he hasn't been seen in
public in years and some people are
saying he's been manipulated or isolated
by some people so that's an interesting
of Rich my disappearance of Richard
Simmons I need a piece of paper help
help Richard Sim Richard Simmons's
probably fat cuz he was fat then well he
well that was kind of part of his stick
was that that's how he become like a
fitness Guru or whatever you want to
call it is f Fitness yeah well you know
I'm I'm with bunny rabbit ear as Eddie
isard says but yeah so um and the
fitness industry is chalk full of
[__] fakes filled with Fakes
including
including Arnold Schwarzenegger he's a
fitness fake all right fck well it's
easy to it's an easy Griff to do like
any kind of nutrition weight loss any
kind if you can come up with something
that sounds easy and kind of crazy and
like not that anything Buddy's done
before then you can like make a [__]
mint on that [__] I respect
Arnold's stuff
on lifting yeah but he
leaves the steroid out he leaves that
out all right he [__] you must take
supplements well he didn't tell you what
the supplement is you know but that's
supplements yeah and the workout
routines he's talking about only work
when you're on those supplements the
[__] normal human would just probably
[__] get smaller or get in get
injured especially if you're older doing
what he's telling you to
do so and then he became a real fake
when he went for that damn Gladiator V
vegan diet thing him and some other guys
cooked
up the vegan secret whatever
no no you're you'll never look like
Arnold did in his prime on a vegan diet
there you'll never meet the protein
requirements and stay underneath the Cal
the caloric intake you need only a
gorilla could do that you're not a
gorilla you know they could eat all
kinds of plant matter last last you
checked but they're [__] eating lots
of that [__] and they they were built to
metabolis
it um then they came out he was saying
well you know the Gladiators were vegans
yeah but the Gladiators were slaves too
and they [__] killed them pretty they
killed him you know so but Pro
Gladiators the big Superstars ate
meat and they also gave them women and
eventually they gave him Freedom here
have a woman have two oh no no no not
only that not they give well they had
prostitutes they give one I know they
were
Superstars and Noble Roman women would
pay to go [__]
yeah yeah kind on the Spartacus show
yeah like they were all they were not
exaggerating they just wanted to jump
right on on his yeah and whoever owned
that gladiator got the proceeds yeah so
the the Gladiator owner was basically
pimping out his Gladiators to the finest
women in in Rome rich women rich young
ones because they were these dudes were
[__] Superstars and of course he got
he got the coach
you know hey we got a present for you
look finest Roman family oh thanks boss
yeah cuz they were in prison they were
prisoners yeah you
know DVD Dragon said bubbles was not
molested lack of opposable thumbs means
no hand jobs see well there you go
that's all that gorillas chimpanzees
have opposable thumbs yeah they do you
talking about that was funny though yeah
yeah I wonder you could you get into
I don't think they have sex like people
do they're not as interested in it they
just jump on a ride and then like like
bye all right as it I don't think
they're thinking about
it okay I've passed on my sperm on to
the next one yeah that's kind of what
they do but yeah so um so obviously this
whole thing here uh never ended up going
to trial uh Michael Jackson did end up
settling I believe it was for 23 minutes
million uh was the settlement and uh you
know they did come out and say well this
not an admission of guilt or blah blah
it's like they just didn't want to go
through the media circus and stuff like
that which like I said fair enough uh
maybe so um so yeah now there was
another kid who was hanging out with
Michael Jackson around this time too
named Brett Barnes he was another one
that was uh quite he was 11 at the time
and he they also kind of paraded him out
like saying uh that he had not been
molested even though he had slept in the
same bed with Michael Jackson his story
was I was on one side of the bed and he
was on the other it was a big bed mly
culan said I think it was on the Larry
King show that Michael Jackson's bedroom
was actually like two stories like I
guess the way he was talking was like it
was like a big bedroom but then it had
like a loft like up above it kind of and
he's like so sometimes like the kids
would sleep up there but the thing about
it was that um and I think that even
Wade the guy from leaving Neverland and
his sister had slept in that Loft up
there but the thing about it though is
that most of the kids said they slept in
Michael Jackson's bed yeah I'm going to
go back to my original
statement how what the [__] is a 30
something year old man doing this for
months on end months on end where are
the women where are the men if you're
gay where are the men you have time for
this [__] have kids over your house
[__] all [__] time months on in
get your [__] kids out of my [__]
house I can get laid you know what I
mean get them out of my [__] house I
got I [__] I got to bust this nut
right well where do you think he's
getting his [__] no this is what he's
into man yeah of course well I mean it's
got to be like I saides a lot more sense
doesn't it it just looks super super
ficial makes a lot more sense like I
said if it was anybody
else who would do that like who who
would let their kid hey go sleep in this
grown man's bed oh it's fine it's not
fine soon as I hear the testimony of
those two other kids you know when they
now they're grown up and they just they
laid it out with the sister system was
it's like oh yeah of course it makes
sense now yeah yeah they're trying to
make it seem like he was trying to make
it seem like it was innocent it like
wasn't any big deal and the thing about
it was I think he may have thought it
was innocent probably yeah well that's
kind of the thing was that and I kind of
you know I I don't know if I necessarily
ever thought just little kids [__]
around they're just little kids yeah but
well and like several people in the
documentary including like Wade's mom
and Wade's grandma and stuff like that
were like oh well he was just like a kid
himself so we didn't really think about
it so some people were just like ah he
you know he they all down near plan
doctor together right like he like he
was just the same age as them so it
wasn't weird but then like the more that
I was like reading through all the stuff
about PDF files and about like this
particular kind of PDF file like which
what he probably was that's exactly what
they do yeah they relate to Children
more they just want to hang out with
children all the time and they do
children things because they're kind of
regress but they're still manipulating
them into doing
[__] that kids should not be doing with
a grown person you know yeah so I and
just the kind of way he went about it
like I said their their stories were
very similar and he probably thinks it's
harmless and it's okay yeah I think he
did think it was Harless think he's a
little kid but no you're not man [__]
you're doing [__] that [__] little
kids don't do yeah you you know you're
sophisticated enough to have a whole
conve conveyor belt system and an age
selection system and a grooming system
and a recruitment system kid don't have
that right and then [__] then all the
finances to fund it and then the [__]
intellect to [__] hide it no you're
not a little kid you're a [__] person
you're you're you're a not a person
you're an adult yeah you're a grown man
a [__] grown ass adult man and no
matter how you [__] spin it you're
taking advantage of these [__]
underage kids yeah they're just kids
yeah I mean you are a grown up seven
that's [__] that's a child yeah you
know big time yeah 14 that's [__]
underage that's a kid you know what I
mean that's a kid it's not a child it's
a kid though and that was when he was
losing interest in them yeah around that
time so child that's what he's into yeah
not even kid child yeah which is [__]
up yeah it's [__] up but um but yeah
so now they did try for a while because
like I remember how I said Evan chaylor
the kid's dad um they had all that
recording of him uh talking about how
he's going to hire a lawyer and he's
going to win and all this other kind of
stuff so actually they did the cops did
look into him for extortion as well
because that was of course how Michael
Jackson's defense team or their lawyers
were going to play it and that's how
they played it in the media that it's
like this guy is just trying to get all
this money out of us which like I said
yes he was I'm not denying that it does
definitely does seem like Evan Chandler
was like cash like going to cash in on
the [__] but that doesn't mean that the
sun was not molested you know what I'm
saying look man this is a 30s something
year old to a 50 something year old dude
you look at the boys that he was hanging
out
with they look like
models especially by the time they get
around 14 or 15 that looks like a boy
model like I said well they were all
actors dancers they were all like in the
entertainment industry or like aspiring
entertainers they weren't just
friends if they were just friends it'd
be a fat
kid you ugly kid fat ugly kid yeah yeah
you're all right dude here have a drink
yeah yeah no these are [__] pretty
boys yeah yeah he definitely seemed to
have kind of a yeah that's what he was
that was what he was going for I mean
they look like they could have been the
secret member of Duran Duran before they
were famous that's what he was yeah
that's what they look like it yeah it is
kind of like it's like a it's suspicious
like a miniature George Michael it's
suspicious yeah so so
yeah um so so like we said earlier um it
was at this point that they did the uh
all the naked photograph
of uh Michael Jackson which like I said
he was very it's just it's so cringy
like watching him pictures of my penis
yeah like watching
him like talk about it it's just I don't
know it's just it made it even more
cringy it yeah it made it like even more
creepy like the way he was talking about
it um I don't know why they thought they
should have released that um now yeah
what I that seemed like like I said it
made it look even
more I read Howard Stern's book I think
it was called private parts I think the
name of the book saw there's a movie too
but I think I think the book was called
private and in there he had a
chapter about the Time Michael Jackson's
people came to him during these
allegations and that they wanted him
to tell everybody that Michael Jackson
would didn't do it yeah and uh Stern
says in the book at this time he said
you know at the time of the reading of
the book and it was a new book when I
got it came out right around the movie
came
out he said he didn't talk about it on
the show he's afraid to talk about a
show he was saving it for the book yeah
he said when he met Michael Jackson
first of all the first thing show up was
a [__] Army of [__] PR people it
was a whole
Entourage and it was like 20 or 30
people and at the back he saw Michael
Jackson and he's [__] see he look
like
a say he was dressed as a member of the
gay
militia that was in a time where Jackson
wore these black little like uniform
things with [__] silver trim and
glasses and [__] I remember that and he
uh had a mask on and a hat and [__]
glasses and he could just see this
little [__] head back there you know
behind the crowd he sits down and
they're just working on Stern for a
[__] half hour or so and then Stern's
people are talking to him
too and he said to get to Jackson you
had to go through a maze of [__]
handlers and they were doing all the
thinking for for
him when it came to this eventually he
he had a chance to [__] sit down next
to Jackson and he said he was sweating
you could see the makeup dripping off
his face and he said he didn't know what
to say to him you know said the only
thing he knew about Jackson was that he
liked deac Chopra yeah oh God okay that
explains a lot yeah which you can have a
[__] AI meme generator [__] give
you dep there actually is a DE
yeah uh sentence generator it's
hilarious his wisdom
[__]
yeah anyway I went I I spent like a
whole hour on the like just one day just
like reading those it was so [__]
funny yeah and [__] he said like
almost nothing goes oh yes I like de sh
very much and fuing the energies are
everywhere that kind of [__] that was
all he [__] said and uh basically all
he [__] said to to to stern and um
Stern got [__] feeling he says he
says he said he said the whole thing was
insane they wanted him they his
Entourage wanted Stern to get on the
radio and basically foment a [__]
Rebellion against the criminal justice
system and all these allegations that
you know that he want you know they
wanted him to actually go out on the
streets with megaphones with [__]
crowds of people and [__] which is hokey
as [__] st's going like I [__] cuz
Stern would do he in in earlier on in
the years but prior to this Stern did
[__] out in public made stunts they
wanted him you know but he kind of
outgrew that they wanted him to go back
to
that and Stern said he just couldn't
[__] go to B for for for for Jack and
he
just he said he just kept seeing those
photographs and and him talking about
the children and [__] stern was like
well if you're so concerned about the
children where are the girls yeah you
know
and he just said it just looked too
[__]
fishy so he kind of had they kind of
they didn't do evidently they didn't do
a non-disclosure thing it's just that he
didn't want to spoil it for the
book yeah and that there was there were
more details to it it a good
story uh but you know he met him for
like a couple hours but only got only
said a couple things to him everything
else was dealing with this Maze of
handlers so what I was trying the reason
why I'm telling the story is
that these things like making the video
on how to deal with the [__]
allegations and him he touching my penis
my butt that was his Entourage and all
these lawyers and all these PR firm
experts that he had hired you and
evidently they did all of his [__] PR
type [__] too or he had PR firms
handling everything that he did this
might have been a very different PR firm
well PR firms man can give very hokey
advice expensive advice might be very
hokey
and I think he paid a lot of money for
that advice to make those
videos maybe in those days your your
average
anmy might buy into that it wouldn't
work today it didn't work on
me I was like that's pretty fishy man I
would never made that video that's very
embarrassing yeah but I think what they
wanted is they wanted sympathy well yeah
I think that's exactly what he was
trying to do like I said he was trying
to like um paint himself as the outraged
VI it's like look what they did to me it
was so
humiliating which you know it yeah it
would be humiliating if you didn't do
the [__] but you know Stern thought it
stanked to high
Haven I mean yeah it it just seems fishy
like I said the whole situation and just
the [__] that he was open about is
sketchy enough you know what I mean he
said being around that guy was like
being on another planet oh I could see
that yeah yeah he just seems like they
were in they were in a reality
suspension field
they suspended reality right and all the
pr people were said he said that they
were totally delusional delusional
Hollywood and PR types yeah because
they're this is their grift that's how
they make money yeah trying to save
people's careers or whatever you know
defend people but he said that they were
not in contact they were not in touch
with the average
person Stern said he looked at those
photographs and he goes people aren't
gonna like that yeah because he looked
at it could see it
just look at it it didn't look right
yeah where are the girls where the black
boys
yeah like I said some people got some uh
theories about that yeah so like I said
far as I know the only black boy that he
hung out with was yeah the and why is
Michael Jackson not black anymore that's
another [__] spooky [__] about that
you know it's just it's a sign of some
[__] weird [__] happening well he had
some he had some problems he had some
very very deep-seated
psychological problems yeah um big time
I mean even aside from all of this stuff
but yeah imagine if some white dude
turned himself black and just started
hanging out with nothing but black boys
that would look [__] they people
would arrest that dude man probably
they're like we don't even know what
we're going to arrest you for I don't
even know what law you're breaking
[__] what the [__] but get off the
street yeah well there's no difference
that's what I mean's no like when it's
the other way like everyone's just like
oh he's just just Ecentric or whatever
no it's it's the white it's it's it's
the white [__] reality suspension
field just cuz you're white you think
it's normal to be white that's a black
dude he's become white right they're
like yeah don't you think imag Str yeah
how much stranger would it be if you saw
a white dude become black remember that
movie Soul Man that came out in the 80s
that really does not play this game yeah
you have a white dude that became black
and he's hanging out with nothing but
pretty little black boys with an
occasional little black girl just for
cover no see that's what I yeah like I
said when you say it like that yeah um
or like I said when you say it like if
it was just like a regular dude that
it's like hey I'm going to build an
amusement park in my front yard and like
have all these little boys over for
sleepovers we're just playing video
games it's like absolutely everyone be
like predator predator you know I got a
whole arcade with [__] standup
console [__] video games I got
Missile Command I got [__] yeah and
the little boys can come over and play
them for free
yeah and we'll hang out yeah and have a
few drinks and we won't tell the parents
but we'll have a few drinks yeah I'll
even let you guys smoke right yeah you
know and the thing is though is if
you're over 14 you're not invited yeah
yeah yeah what the [__] we only want the
cute young ones
[__] yeah that's what I mean when you
lay it out like that it's clearly it's
clearly what it is it is it is what it
is it is what it appears to be yeah
people are what they appear to be no
matter they say don't judge a book by
the cover no in general judge a book by
the cover people are what they appear
you see a dude down in a gutter pissed
stained toothless hasn't showered in
[__] six months you know what you're
dealing with and he is what he appears
exactly as he
appears but yeah so after all these
photographs that they took because they
they had to show them to the kid because
they wanted to kind of like prove that
it's like you know compare his testimony
with what the dick actually looked like
I guess it's like I'm sorry for making
you think think about Michael Jackson's
dick but um so according to some of the
detectives that worked on the case and
um the da and the photographer and
everything like that uh they actually
thought that Jordan's description of his
penis matched the photos but apparently
some other people thought not and I
think there was a controversy too
because I think Jordan said that he was
circumcised and he's not now Danny
Ghostface comes in says maybe he did it
because he was experiencing racism so he
was trying to become another no Michael
Jackson was loved since he was a child
yeah all right no he was a [__]
celebrity when he was a child yeah I was
a little kid remember ABC one two three
it'd be on television man I couldn't
tell the difference between Michael
Jackson and Rodney Isen Rick because I
saw Rodney Isen R I said where the [__]
because I saw him at the Pike me and his
mom and my mom were hanging out we were
[__] on the ferris wheel me and
Rodney Allen R you know who that is he
was a
little he was a spokes person for Jack
in a box he was he was he was the same
age as so it was kind of like a more of
like a local cele yeah yeah California
California yeah yeah Southern California
and he thought he thought that kid and
Michael Jackson yeah I thought they knew
each other they both they're both black
they both had afro they're both on
television they know each other the two
black every time they see me every time
they're on television I wave to them
that's how I used think I used to think
they could see me for a while you know
you thought people on TV could see you
yeah a that's so cute for a little while
that's so cute my dad had to tell me
they can't see you so they can't see me
you're just like sit there talking yeah
yeah I'm talking to buy hey
hey Rod Allen riy was his name Rod Allen
Rod Allen Rippy yeah but uh no [__]
Michael Jackson didn't experience any
racism he was loved since he was a
[__] child by the public he was
[__]
Superstar yeah I mean you know so no he
just he was just transracial he didn't
like black people he wanted to be white
I mean that's what some of his staff
have said that he really did not like
like really did not like black people
like he kind of sounded like you know
like my old southern Grandpa yeah that
kind of not liking black people um but
yeah it was that kind of thing was like
oh they're all thieves and they're all
lazy and they're not like other people
and he would say stuff like that
allegedly like that's what some of his
like the only racism Michael Jackson
experience was his own he didn't like
black people well like I said I don't
even know like I just think he had a
real like Winterfell said earlier like I
think that he just had a real problem
with like self-hatred well probably
started with the family yeah yeah he
didn't like he didn't get along with his
family so he was trying to reboot who he
was when he got money he rebooted yeah
and he wanted to be a different person
that's what I was I yeah I think that's
what it was like he just wanted to
distance himself like as far as possible
and he just wanted to look completely
different you know what I mean so so
yeah so we talked about Latoya before
saying that uh
she she kind of went back and forth on
it like At first she was kind of like oh
I support my brother he'd never do
anything like that then she comes out is
like oh he's totally a PDF file and then
um you know she said something like uh I
think she told Katie coric it's like
that he had boys over all the time and
they'd stay in his room for days then
they come out they bring another boy um
and he said he never had two at a time
like which she thought was fishy also
said that she saw checks that he wrote
out like to the families which was
supposedly supposed to be hush money um
but then like people tried to discredit
her too because they said well oh well
she haded to sell that story to a
tabloid for like half a million dollars
so maybe that I don't really know but um
and then like I said later on she
recanted the story and said oh my
abusive ex-husband like made me say it
for some reason I don't really know um
so there's that now uh so right around
this time like I said um a little less
than a year after uh the allegations
came out and like they were trying to
reach a settlement or whatever um he
married Lisa Marie press now they had
met a long time ago I think they met
like still while Elvis was still alive
like when she was kind of young I almost
went to high school with Lisa Marie yeah
really yeah my mom's boyfriend she was
going to marry him he was a [__]
chemical engineer lived up in [__]
ohigh and that was the local private
school was in ohigh that's [__] Lisa
Marie went to ohigh good thing I didn't
go she said she hated that school it's
nothing but
snot none of a snots mostly mostly
celebrity
kids good thing I didn't go to ohigh
[__] that
place but yeah so apparently they'd been
friends a long time ago and I guess like
when all of this [__] was going on like
they kind of sort of reconnected like
friendship and I guess he was calling
her all the time like commiserating like
or you know complaining about how mean
the media was him and stuff so um she
said at least at the time that she
believed he didn't do anything wrong um
and that he was wrongly accused and said
yes I started falling for him I wanted
to save him um
so basically he just one during one of
these phone conversations he just said
if I ask you to marry me would you do it
now later on like I said she did C come
out and say that she was angry she
called herself disposable that was the
word that she used um and she said that
even at the time that he was asking
about her marrying him when all of this
[__] was going on um Debbie row was also
around like I said he'd known her for a
long time too cuz she worked for him or
wor or was related to somebody that
worked for him and um and he was just
like well if you don't do it I'll get
her to do it so he just wanted somebody
it seemed like and even in the media at
the time they were saying that it was
just like a publicity stunt to distract
everybody from the abuse allegations you
know it's like look he's normal like he
you know he married an adult woman yeah
you know she was pretty at this time she
was was gorgeous yeah she was gorgeous
there was a really weird interview like
I saw part of this interview with him
and Lisa Marie I was it with Barbara
Walters I can't remember who it was but
it was somebody that was um asking them
about it and they were asking because at
this time Lisa Marie so like I said she
had just divorced her divorce was just
finally like three weeks before she
married Michael Jackson and she had a
couple of kids with her previous husband
yeah and they were ask she was asking if
Michael Jackson
would adopt Lisa Marie's kids and he was
like well the weird thing about it is
like she kind of asked that question
like pretty straightforwardly I thought
and then he's like I love all the
children I want to adopt I want to help
all the children the Arab children and
the Jewish children I'm just like what
are you talking about so it's like the
fact that he went off like that and then
she was like no would you adopt Lisa
Marie's children that was what she meant
and he was like oh of course of course
and then Lisa Marie was just kind of
like like she didn't want I can't
remember exactly what she said but the
way she said it was like well oh well
they have a biological father you know
what I mean like so it was like really
really weird like the way that she said
it like the way she phrased it I think
Lisa Marie also either dated or was
married to Nicholas Gage wasn't she oh
was she yeah I don't remember that I
think maybe just dated Nicholas Cage
maybe because I remember she said she
got sick of him asking questions about
Elvis about her father and he would he
was a huge
Elvis he he could do Elvis
impersonations she said it was well like
I said didn't you ever see that David
Lynch movie Wild at Heart his like whole
his love for Elvis is a whole plot Point
yeah yeah evidently he could you know
she got kind of she thought it was kind
of creepy she's like he was more into my
dad than he was into me yeah maybe that
was the whole reason he dated her he's
like hey give me all the give me all the
tea on Elvis cuz it's like you know that
would be pretty weird like not to be D
pretty sure it was Nicholas Cage for
yourself nich cage is a big Elvis fan so
Nicholas Cage I'll have to look it up
cuz I don't remember that specifically
but um I guess they weren't married just
they were dating I think yeah yeah cuz I
don't I don't I don't know like I said I
don't follow a lot of celebrities so
it's just kind of I vaguely remember
stuff like from the 80s and 90s but
after that I don't have any idea but she
was married to somebody I can't remember
what his name was but he I don't think
he was super yeah at least proof that if
you got good-looking parents you're
going to be
good-look not always not always I think
most of the time lot of you know if long
as plastic surgery wasn't involved and
have surgery but yeah she seemed um kind
of more willing to she didn't really say
anything shitty about I mean like I said
they were married for what like 18
months or something like that and then
like she filed for divorce like um that
marriage was never consummated come on
you know that you know well that's yeah
and I and I think that I think for a
long time she wasn't really supposed to
talk about it because she thought she'd
get in trouble I don't think she got a
big settlement or nothing like that but
it's just like she didn't get any money
I don't think I don't know but um yeah
and it's just weird that it happened
when it happened and like I said
remember it was I think it was the Video
Music Awards or something and then they
had like the both of them come out
because there had been [__] in the media
like why is he just like marrying her
randomly like all of a sudden it like
that seems really weird and suspicious
it's you know the timing of it and um
you know and then they came out and
kissed and it was just like I was like
oh you just made it worse cuz it was
like so creepy it was just like so
uncomfortable Allison said yeah they
dated oh okay and he said something
about gag order I don't know yeah yeah
different subject she's talking about
there well yeah maybe like she might
have had I think she did have gag order
because like I said I saw she could she
couldn't talk around [__] Stern Stern
asked her a bunch of questions she
wouldn't answer it she was like yeah
he'd probably sue my ass yeah I think
that's what it was she could so yeah she
might have signed something yeah but
yeah I don't think anybody ever thought
that he had sex with Lisa Marie and I'm
pretty sure that it's common knowledge
that he didn't have sex with Debbie row
his second wife either even though they
were married for three years cuz those
kids are not his those kids are not
biological Al his like he got sperm
donors so you know for whatever reason
so yeah so as I said um he'd been
addicted to painkillers for a while he
actually got on painkillers remember the
very famous like the Pepsi commercial
when his hair caught on fire yeah and it
burned like a lot of his scalp off which
like that's not funny but you know what
I mean um so he was on painkillers and
he had to go through all kind of surgery
like when that happened obviously so he
got addicted to painkillers at that
point and then kind of moved on to other
stuff and like I said he had um real bad
insomnia apparently and so he was just
getting like stronger and stronger like
[__] uh sedatives and stuff like that
so um so yeah
now all right so
1993 he kind of
like got away with it I guess because
they came to a settlement it seemed
like and it still seems like nowadays
because every like documentary or
anything that I watch like on YouTube
about it it seemed like the majority may
I don't know maybe maybe this is maybe
I'm just reading it wrong but it's just
it does seem like the majority of people
still think that he didn't do it and
still think that he's innocent
and I don't know like I get like if
you're a big fan of his that you don't
want to believe that but it's just like
I kind of feel like other celebrities if
they had done anything as egregious as
this like as open as this like cuz a lot
of stuff I said like he said he just
kind of did in the open and didn't seem
to see anything wrong with it I think
people would be up in arms about it if
it was somebody different or somebody
not as famous or something like that so
it's just kind of like it kills me the
way and somebody I think it was um
wasn't it uh I think it was Chris Rock
like on his special where he was talking
about like people would give Michael
Jackson to pass but then like R Kelly
like got in trouble R Kelly that was
underage girls but still um you know but
he's like it's the same thing so like
why does Michael Jackson get it pass and
R Kelly doesn't you know what I mean so
you know you can kind of see his point
because it's it's the same thing it's
just one's girls and one's boys there's
no difference it's still like abuse so
so yeah I feel
like um at this
point I don't know I kind of feel like
the media at the time back in 1993
everybody was kind of like they thought
he probably did it
but I don't know he still kind of got
away with it because like a lot of his
fans still supported him
and it didn't really it hurt his career
a little bit but not really all that
much you know what I mean but the
tabloids had a [__] field day with it
you know what I mean like where it was
just like every single thing and I
remember like the UK tabloids in
particular used to call him wacko Jacko
which um like they that was what they
called him like all the time so which uh
I saw somebody point out too they're
like that's actually in British terms uh
that's actually kind of racist too
because Jacko is referring to like a
monkey so um so yeah so there's that but
uh but yeah so there was there was a lot
of [__] about it but it eventually kind
of blew over because they you know he he
did the [__] settlement right so he
goes to like a drug rehab in the UK for
a little while um and then it seemed
like for a little while afterward like
even in the 9s still I think they did
some polls in the US to see like how
many people like thought he was guilty
only 25% like of the public despite all
the tabloids coming out and like
basically saying he was guil the
tabloids always had a [__] bad
credibility so whatever the tabloids
said usually was quite the opposite was
the truth was the opposite then they saw
the thing they took pictures of me he
did get some
sympathy there wasn't any proof right so
Americans are going to go you know
Norm's going to go yeah they couldn't
prove it probably didn't happen yeah but
they were trying
to
they you weren't sitting down with these
people going
look another thing is is that he had he
had celebrity Shield the celebrity
Distortion field a lot of people back in
this days especially the older people
thought if you were a celebrity you [__]
you you're okay you know you can't
almost do no wrong you know they had
people that were like that they were
Gods I they get away with a lot of I
mean they still get away with a lot of
stuff so they but even more back then
but it wasn't being presented to them
the evidence wasn't being presented to
them like we presented it here like look
if you know if you had a dude moving
moving next door and he starts putting
[__] Ferris wheels and [__] kids
toys out in front
and an arcade in the back and invites
all the boys between the ages of seven
your house and he doesn't have any kids
and he got no and he's got [__] you
know invo inviting all and he's [__]
in his 40s you know inviting all the
boys seven to 14 over the house if
you're over 14 you can't come you're not
invited that's going to be some [__]
crazy [__] there people are going to
[__] call the cops on that dude man I
know that's the thing yeah people dad's
going to go down there and [__] touch
that [__] up give him a full
tuneup stay with my son that's what I
mean feel like and I kind of feel like
every dad yeah and moms too probably the
moms too yeah like if you thought that
somebody was doing that to your kids
especially in the South holy crap you
would kill that [__] yeah in the
South they're not even called the cops
most people they're just going to tune
you right the [__] up that's just going
to
happen well like I said um even even
Cory Feldman said that like in the
interview and it it was kind of an old
interview that I saw with him but when
he was saying about Michael Jackson
showing him the weird book with like the
genital the the genital diseases in it
yeah and all these diseases you don't
want to have sex with women don't have
sex with women they give you I know I
wonder was he telling prob yeah and he
was like 13 at the time so this is what
happens to people who have sex with
women yeah they're
dirty oh my God Ed mom you catch this
from a woman's vagina yeah look at that
that's disgusting come here women are so
gross let me show let me show you how to
stay
clean yeah yeah this is clean cuz we're
you know it's all clean we're on the
outside everything's on the out the air
can get to
it I know women are so women are so
gross and dirty and mysterious cuz all
their [__] interior it's all in the
inside it's all on the inside it's not
supposed to be like that let me show you
something bend
over oh man just relax no that's what he
told him probably that's what he said I
mean well I mean that's yeah know he
didn't say use that word no not Cory
Feldman like that other guy yeah but
like I said he didn't um he didn't say
all that stuff about they were watching
straight porn I think well see that's
another thing now when when the FBI or
like when the cops like raided Neverland
and went through there they found I
don't think they found like any straight
up um Kitty
prawns but they did find
um some books that had pictures of naked
boys in them okay and like two or three
books with pictures naked boys and they
found a picture in the house of a naked
boy that was they think was one of the
accusers yeah you know what I mean so
that was suspicious but they did find a
[__] ton of straight porn too and they
thought well that's normal for a guy to
have that was like in his bedroom but
some of the kids said that he showed
them por porn yeah like either in
magazines or like later on like on his
computer yeah so that's what I was going
to that's why I was saying I don't think
that Jackson saw himself as gay I think
I think he saw himself as straight he
knew the little boys were straight he
was flipping him and he's not going to
show him anything homosexual it's it's
gonna he it's gon to scare him that's
what because we were talking about that
cuz cuz the the GU on that documentary
said yeah he he would show us porn yeah
and they said it was straight porn right
and Tom's like well that's a little bit
weird but then he thought about it a
second then he was like oh well maybe he
thought like if he showed them gay porn
that it would like scare them cuz that
would be like too weird or something
yeah you know what I mean well I think I
think there were something about it I
think he saw himself as a straight
little white
boy that was fooling around with other
straight little white boys that's what
he thought cuz he expected them to get
girlfriends when they got older andbody
ask him about it right right and I don't
think way the guy described it I don't
think it was out of jealousy I think it
was out of
curiosity because I think I got a weird
feeling that technically Michael Jackson
was a
virgin I kind of got that feeling too
yeah you know like as far as as far as
with women right yeah so I don't think I
don't think he got much in terms of
penetration from those boys just oral it
does seem like most of the allegations
were yeah oral sex and mutual
masturbation yeah he attempted some some
rear entry [__] but it didn't work out
yeah so evidently evidently according to
sources that we have so maybe he was
trying to like work up to that but
like I don't think he was trying to work
up to anything because I think uh his
personality was not
about progression it was more about
staying in a fixed childlike State yeah
so I don't think he was thinking about
evolving forward into new things staying
regressed staying in a childlike state
of kind of a
[__] semi- asexual kid just first
fooling around you know playing doctor
with his friends that's what I it did
kind of come across like that that's
because it's all innocent and they're
all just ignorant you know it's like
that that's what I think he's doing it's
like Peter Pan would you drink out of
the water we we could fly we can fly you
know he's you know what kind of
yeah and then but like like I said like
a lot of the kids said that he would
yeah yeah that he would like jerk off in
front of them yeah and then he would
yeah yeah and he's like you want me to
show you how to do it or I can do it for
you and stuff like that like he was
doing that kind of [__] yeah so I don't
know
man but yeah so um so yeah so they so
the um Jordan Chandler and the family
they actually they were going to do a
criminal trial and they also try to do
like a civil they try to do like a civil
lawsuit um but they there was like this
whole big thing about it it's like well
you know we can't have the Civil Trial
and the criminal trial going at the same
time blahy blah and then eventually they
just decided to settle out a court like
I said so they put all this money in a
trust fund for Jordan and gave some to
his parents and stuff like that like I
said I think it was about $23 million um
how much he paid out for that and he
said um that he just wanted to get on
with his life um and just get back to
what he was good at which was you know
making records and stuff and he didn't
want there to be a whole media circus
but he did say later on that he actually
did regret settling and so when he was
accused again in 2005 he actually did go
and fight it in court that but this one
he did not he just like settled out of
court now our gay friend Victor Garcia
in there says that Michael Jackson was
gold star gay I don't know the gay
ranking system maybe there's a silver
star two bronze star gay you know but he
said he's gold star gay
yeah he was gay but I don't think he saw
himself as
that yeah saw as a little boy I yeah I
definitely do think like I said he was
self-loathing in a lot of ways um he
didn't want to be black and he didn't
want to he didn't want to be an adult
man yeah he wanted to be a little boy he
didn't want to be gay and especially an
adult man with gay feelings yeah he
didn't want to be gay either he didn't
want to have that yeah so he's just like
he was trying to make himself into
something compl he was too scared to
girls he was he was too scared to girls
that killed me when he said Tatum O'Neal
[__] scared him now I heard Tatum had
a [__] rough oh she did she was like
in Hollywood orgies at 12 I think if I
remember correctly yeah but she was 19
at the time that she was but yeah so the
fact that a 24-year-old man
just kind of lays there and puts his
hands over his face like if you can't
see me then I don't exist like like that
like when a 19-year-old when his
19-year-old supposed girlfriend or
person he's dating is like just trying
to [__] him yeah that's that says a lot
and the fact that and and like I said
that's not even alleged he said that
yeah he told that
story so you know T O'Neal would skull
drag Michael Jackson he couldn't handle
it too much
woman yeah probably true too much woman
probably true yeah he's cover his eyes
oh my God is say
was you too much for me right now I just
yeah I can't imagine being that
terrified but you T put the [__] on you
right on you bam boom Victor says drop
it on you Victor says gold star gay
means they've never slept with a woman
oh is that what that is okay yeah gold
star gay now you know you learn Now
understand it's a gay ranking
system it's ingenious it's in it's
Inus I I don't think I'd ever heard that
phrase actually I knew that there were a
lot of gay I've recorded that now yeah
I've recorded that oh Tom's going to use
that absolutely yeah but it's like I
said I don't know why people would think
that was unusual cuz it's like well
there's a lot of straight people that
haven't slept with the same sex either
so it's like why would it be weird gold
star straight yeah why would it be weird
like for a game man never I didn't think
they would keep a score yeah I think gay
are keeping score on that gold star G
okay you're safe then you're part of I
can trust you yeah not one of those like
you're not one of them [__] yeah
bronze star gay the bronzear kind of
just G not quite as good yeah
yeah gay when you want to be gay when
you want to be man I saw a [__]
badass shirt Jenny Jen's like you buy
that shirt it says I'm not gay but $20
is $20 that's
[__] he showed it realiz I was like yeah
fcking please get that shirt I'm like
that is so funny wear that [__]
streaming it'd be funny as [__] that was
off of t- yeah t I think it was green it
was like a it green muscle shirt it was
like a green muscle shirt with it says
it says Big B I'm not gay it says gay
big but $20 is
$20 with the dollar sign but
$20 I was like that is so [__] funny
I would die laughing if you wore that
[__] shirt that would be so [__]
awesome you need that wear that [__] on
stream mate yeah you you need that shirt
I think yeah like CU I just he showed
that I would [__] go to bike night
with that shirt on I would go I would go
to bike night with that shirt I would
walk around a bikers and they' be like
what the [__] they would laugh well yeah
that's a funny ass
shirt Victor said $20 May me
gay yeah it could happen to any boy it
happens all the time Victor don't don't
don't be don't be don't be shy don't be
embarrassed Happ all boys I just I
really do think you need that shirt that
that like I I want a photograph of you
if I have to photoshop it I will if you
wearing that shirt we could just print
one up I could make one yeah you just
make one oh yeah that' probably be
cheaper it be cheaper just like make it
yeah oh my
God it's just it's like [__]
hilarious I had forgotten about that so
you just like mentioned it again I'm
like oh my God you need that so
bad that's that's a gay for pay shirt
yeah what star gay are you Victor if
you're gay for
pay yeah there's got to be a ranking for
yeah that's probably not even bronze
star that's probably like 10 star yeah
that's you're a 10 star yeah yeah if
you're just gay for pay
it's like yeah it's like I'm straight
but I'll blow you for $20 you know what
I mean $20 is $20 that's [__] funny
yeah $20 is a lot of
money I probably need more than that
like to yeah no [__] escort escort's
going to go 300 minimum [__] yeah I'm
just like I'm not street hooker is going
to be like 40 or 50 yeah I I I don't
even know if there's any amount of money
that you can give me to like to blow a
random dude like it's just I don't know
she got to know you that's that's what I
mean you know that's funny I mean at
least for a little while it's like she
got to know you I don't I know what your
bring problem is you know what I mean so
yeah um so so I was watching this other
video because they brought up um this
book that came out that was written by
this uh journalist named Victor uh
Gutierrez and he wrote a book that was
allegedly based on um Jordan Chandler's
diaries now I don't know how [__]
this book B is um the journalist
apparently like spent a long time like
researching This and like talk to
various people and he supposedly said in
the book that um I don't know if I don't
think like Michael Jackson ever went to
a nbla meeting but apparently like the
dudes at nbla like thought that he was
one of them you know what I mean like
hey it's another one like us like you
know what I mean you you know who NAMBLA
is right yeah yeah most people know who
namble is like look at or I was going to
say look it up but don't no
probably end up on a list yeah you
probably end up on a list somewhere so
man I got introduced by to to n by
[__] haral Rivera haraldo Rivera's
[__] talk show had them [__]
on there remember that back in the 80s R
right kind of exposed it and they were
some of those dudes were there with
pictures of them nude with their little
boyfriends they're trying to like
normalize yeah these are like [__]
seveny olds and [__] which they were on
the talk show on the [__] panel no
they were showing the pictures man they
had like in their underwear and [__]
that's what I mean that's kind of like
what I mean that's kind of like what MJ
was like because it was just kind of
like he didn't really seem to see a
problem Hero's crowd didn't know how to
react to it for a while like CU they
were like the the the the the the
members of that group were trying to
make it sound like it was legit like oh
yeah this is just this is just you know
how the world is eventually towards the
middle part of that program remember the
[__] the [__] audience was [__]
just outrage I I was going to say I
can't imagine audience would just like
get up there and like rip them all the
pieces think because man it didn't work
out for them it's uh and that was the
end that's a hard cell that was the end
of that assoc that was the end of that
group MBL nbla yeah that was the end of
them in public for a long time they they
had evidently people kept checking back
with them raldo Rivera but kept checking
back with them the only thing they had
was a [__] phone line and an
answering machine they wouldn't
answer that but evidently they're back
they went way on the down yeah evidently
they're back that they they still exist
to to today well yeah it probably just
went farther underground I imagine yeah
and it was basically a political it was
a group
[__] PDF files yeah a ring of them
that would pick up under
AG boys and trade them like trading
cards yeah and then they had a political
veneer of political movement over it
over the top of it and lawyers and [__]
they were trying to get it all
legalized yeah that's what I'm saying
which like I said no imagine imagine
like the [__] one of those Mormon
separatist Cults but
for you know what I mean for [__] you
know PDF files where they just had were
they traded yeah no that's not a good
analogy I
guess got lost in it there just a bunch
of creepy old men [__] with with like
[__] super young no some of those
Mormon Mormon separatist [__] Cults
did that creepy old men with all trading
these girls yeah but at least they were
kind they were legal age those girls but
supposedly not always but these kids
were like [__] seven eight nine yeah
[__]
that victure says Tom's going to get
home with a bunch of $20 bills in his
pocket yeah be like what have you been
man [__] I hope so how many dudes would
you blow I'm listening to her but
she you GNA film you gonna film it
no what do you get though I ain't gonna
do
it it was funny because he went I'm
trying go ahead go well no cuz he went
to I'm trying to spend some kind of yarn
and she comes how many dudes you gonna
blow just D you let me warm up to the
story I was going to [__] spin some
kind of [__] [__] story know it
sounded cool but you know know I just
thought I'd cut RAC in the chase how
many dudes you got to
BL give me a number come on I had I I
had to back out of it back out of it all
no okay no no no it's just funny because
well well he went to going up with all
this money
Where damn I'm counting
it it's like man you used to do that
more often and then the then the
[__] get sick of me and the
money dries up you're like honey where's
the money money
is they're not interested they're not
biting a sounds like cute enough I'm
used up I'm used up yeah poor
Tom we need to like move to a new area
so you can like got to move to a new
area to start over got to go on tour
like all the other hoes going on tour
there you go
yeah it's funny because like well he
went to bike night the other night and I
went on streamate just by myself like
trying to make some money and uh it's
funny because he had his tablet with him
so he can come in the room so he's like
coming in the room like pretty funny
there's a dude trying to cook me out you
know there was yeah yeah he kept making
me he wanted me to well he wanted me to
call you first and I was like well you
don't have a phone so I was like well
it's I can text him or like Facebook
message or whatever and it's like that
um I had to tell you I had to tell you
that his dick was bigger than yours yeah
like the size of a forearm or yeah
something like that and he was 18 yeah
like he he was very a pro I'm I'm
answering in the chat line and I said
did you prove it did you go private turn
the camera on cuz that cost money yeah
that no he didn't see and I'm like if
you're not proving it then you ain't
[__] right that's what I'm saying
because you got to pay to prove that
[__] yeah cuz some dudes have said some
[__] they turn the camera on and sure
enough I'm sitting there yes sir you
know that [__] [__] huge yeah
yeah it's really weird it's either the
people that turn their cameras on are
either people with huge dicks or people
with really really tiny ones yeah they
want you to want that want you to make
fun of them make fun of them yeah if
it's little that's surprisingly common
yeah but you know okay everybody got of
how could you be so much bigger than me
yeah that's say genetics yeah oh yeah we
had that guy a couple of times yeah yeah
was that same guy was it yeah he's Irish
or something yeah from the accent and
[__] I can't here's the [__] thing
the picture the the our [__] screen
is the side it's it's a [__] laptop
screen the picture that they you see
when they turn on the camera is like
this big you can't see anything you you
can't really see anything I mean you
kind but you got to pretend like you see
you're seeing [__] because you got a
role play right you get a general idea
of what's happening but you just can't
especially we don't have our glasses on
yeah cuz that's cuz I'm just like I
don't know you're just like a little
blurry thumb I don't know what that
is he's you know it's so small it's okay
dude it's going to be okay yeah I'm I'm
not I'm not [__] I'm not so ruthless
like yeah you [__] suck but they got
they got some dudes that into that into
that you are [__] you suck man you're
never going to get they get off on with
that [__] get off on possible they
getting off on how little it is I I have
a hard time doing that I do too it's
like I mean and I'm not saying I'm not
mean cuz I am but it's just kind of like
in that kind of situation when I don't
know you yeah that dude's all pitiful
and [__] over like I'm just like oh I
just feel bad I can't all right man now
I'll be mean to somebody I know like
you know what I mean yeah I'll do that
CU it's like I know they know that I'm
just [__] around but you know what I
mean not to like a random person that's
mean Victor said if I had a dollar for
every dude I've blown I'd have like $20
if I had a dollar for every dude that's
blown me I'd be retired damn you a
player just think about that AER think
about if you had gotten a dollar from
every single one of those gay player in
the house he's a top You' Be A
Millionaire a millionaire all this
[__] all these effeminate gays
[__] lining up to blow
him Ben says people will pay he's pretty
people will pay you to laugh at them for
having a small penis I'm in the wrong
business they will it's like I said it's
not as unusual as you might think yeah
like I guess that's like a whole it's a
whole Kink for them yeah I mean we get a
lot of kind of like people wanting us to
abuse them in various ways but we have
had a few people that like have really
really small yeah penises and they
wanted us to like berate them about in
general the dudes that turn on the the
cameras though in general most of them
are [__] Fitness guys I would say
like 90% of them are like in good shape
and have like real good shape and have
like big dicks Fitness guys and they're
cool they're like yeah you guys are
great you know he's trying to [__]
outdo Us in the show he's got his own
little camera you see him he's like he's
doing push-ups and [__] and [__]
something you can't tell what it is he
this is awesome dude said we're having a
threesome
yeah I like that guy he's been in a he's
been in a coup a couple cool I like him
yeah and he's always on for a long time
too yeah he'll [__] be on there 15
minutes yeah [__] you're G to make
[__] 60 70 bucks off him yeah it's
cool and then like uh he'll
uh he's funny though we haven't seen
that guy in a while though let see yeah
I mean he might be on like tomorrow
night he's usually on in the evenings I
think he's in good shape though he's
shredded yeah he's shred yeah yeah he's
he looks like a big dude you can't yeah
like 20 something a lot of them are
young young fit shredded yeah they're
not older guys they're younger guys I
don't yeah that's weird I expected more
middleaged or older dudes and it's
almost it's almost universally like
young like guys in their 20s almost
universally
yeah Allison said can we talk about
furries I'm a furry name is
Bubbles we gotta get back to Michael
Jackson yeah I mean well okay so um so
yeah so like I said he did have the
three kids that are you know I think
everybody knows that they're like not
biologically his there was that whole do
you remember that whole brewhaha when
blanket was a baby and he was in Germany
I think and all the crowd was like hey
we want the baby and he put the baby
like over the balcony and was like what
the [__] are you doing you're going to
drop the [__] baby and there was like
a huge thing about it and of course he
like I think it was an accident though
yeah but I mean who dangles their baby
over a bcon he was just showing it to
the crowd he didn't I don't think he
realized it was over the damn railing
and people like I don't know of the
balcony you need to like put some more
forethought and it's that's a baby you
know what I mean you can't can't just
like drop a baby that was Michael
Jackson though he crazy it's true I mean
this [__] he's not thinking
rationally I guess not it's just kind of
like yeah so the thing about it so they
had these kids like I said with Debbie
row now Debbie row she um divorced him
in 2000 so I think they were married for
two and a half three years something
like that now she gave him custody of
the kids and got an $8 million
settlement $8 million back in 20 000 now
in 2004 when there was that second set
of abuse allegations came out she
actually went back to court and wanted
to get the kids back although I think
they settled out of court because she
was afraid that you know he was doing
something to them which you know was
understandable so what happened with the
second case so this was a kid named
Gavin um arviso is I think you how you
pronounce his last name now Michael
Jackson would do a lot of stuff with you
know just kids in general but uh you
know terminally ill kids thank you
Victor good show here's $20 some now you
have to blow him dang
it it's got we'll do that [__] cyber I
got some new material coming it's going
to come up on fley all right and I think
I haven't put anything up on it yet but
it' probably be for it's going to be for
a male audience yeah you haven't put
anything on yet Jen I I send you videos
all the time I sent him like a whole
bunch of pictures last night like while
I was Jenny Jenny Jenny see seen some of
the tricks that I could do over [__]
time she's like that is so [__]
hot I'm like do it I got all kinds of
torture pumps and [__] like that yeah I
try to like make him send me videos and
stuff but he just doesn't make them he
doesn't make them like I said I send him
videos all the time but and then he
sends them to random
people no they're not random people
they're fans're they're your
fans he he tells me later like I sent
him like four pictures or something like
in the video last night from when I was
streaming cuz I farting around with the
different stuff I didn't know it was
Private Oh I thought that was stuff that
was going to go up on Twitter well I was
going to put it up on Twitter yes that's
not private that's promot I didn't get
to because my my uh phone lost its
connection and I couldn't upload it
that's promotional material that's not
yeah picture said a [__] Apple took
their penny Okay but yeah so okay so
this kid like so Michael Jackson did a
lot of work with like like I said like
terminally ill kids and stuff like that
so this kid had cancer right and this
comedian introduced this kid to Michael
Jackson because this kid's dad um the
parents were separated I think and he
would go around asking different
celebrities to like good a bat for the
kid and like help them out with all the
Cancer Treatments which are you know
expensive obviously so there was that
like he had to get like his one of his
kidneys removed and his spleen and [__]
like that so he really did have they
weren't faking him having cancer he
really did have cancer
so during the course of this like while
the family was trying to get money for
the kids Cancer Treatments Jackson and
Gavin you know became friends or
whatever and
again Michael invited the whole family
over to Neverland and he would stay
there like for a while but the thing
about it was that Gavin was the kid that
was in that documentary called living
with Michael Jackson so he was actually
kind of like living there for a little
while but I don't really know and like I
said that was the one that he was like
all cuddled up next to him and like they
were holding hands and it was like super
weird because the kids like you know 13
or something like that like
nobody nobody acts like that with a like
a grown man doesn't act like that with a
13-year-old kid you know what I mean
it's just I don't know it's weird but
then Gavin later said that um after he
had been to Neverland a few times like
Michael stopped calling him and Gavin
like felt really bummed out about it
like he'd been pleased you know what I
mean and that was something that um the
other guys like on leaving Neverland
said too that they when there was
another boy brought up like they would
see the pattern and they'd be like Oh
I'm being replaced you know what I mean
they get like yeah and they'd get like
really bummed out about it Jackson was
smooth man he was smooth I mean yeah so
he's a player uh yeah and then yeah
Smooth Criminal
yeah yeah that's the thing so they did
this documentary and I've seen the clip
from this documentary it's super creepy
right like he's sitting on the couch
with this kid and the guy who made the
documentary Martin Basher he says well
don't you think it's
inappropriate that you are sharing a bed
and having sleepovers with these boys
you know what I mean um and he said no
it's beautiful and he's just like why
can't you share your bed that's the most
loving thing to do to share your bed
with someone so like he absolutely just
did not seem to like think anything was
wrong with it so after this documentary
came out because I kind of feel like he
made this documentary and this is you
know only a few years this probably
seven eight years like after the you
know the first allegations You' think he
would have like put a kibos on hanging
out with little boys like just so it
didn't look bad this just his sexual
orientation it's not going yeah and it's
like well that's what I mean that's why
I kind of think he probably did it
because he just couldn't stop like he
couldn't help himself no that's like
stopping being straight or stopping
being gay it's not going to happen yeah
that's what I mean like serial killer
it's not going to happen right serial
killers that's their orientation that's
what they do yeah I mean that's just the
way this right and it's just kind of
like so it's that so so he supposedly
made this documentary like this
documentary guy like came and stayed
with him for like several months and
they made this that was supposed to I
guess like make his Public Image better
but it did kind of the opposite cuz
everyone was like that is some creepy
[__] like right there with that kid and
then they started saying maybe they
should take his kids away because he
might be like doing some [__] for them
or anything like that so there's that
now um so a bunch of other stuff like I
said that we talked about like dangling
the baby over the balcony and he started
acting I don't know if this was just
because of stress or because of all the
drugs he was on or something um but he
was at the MTV Video Music Awards I
think in 2002 and they said he was
acting really weird like all disoriented
and when they would like interview him
sometimes like he seemed like he
couldn't remember [__] and everything
like that so it seemed like he was kind
of spiraling uh downwards a little bit
and so after this documentary came out
um in
2003 the um La Department of Child and
Family Services they did a like they
started looking into um you know abuse
allegations they went back to uh the
Jordan case and then they T were
thinking about like uh interviewing and
Gavin and stuff as well and they
initially thought maybe there was
nothing to it but then like one of the
other investigator said I think there is
something to it so then they reopened
the investigation like later on that
year so they interviewed Gavin and his
dad and his mom and younger brother and
Gavin at that point told the cops that
Michael had molested him like several
times like over the period of a month in
um now the mom actually said that they'd
been held captive at Neverland I'm not
sure if that was the case because I
think yeah because I think that later on
they were able to find like um evidence
that she had actually been out and about
like shopping and like at restaurants
and stuff cuz receipts and things she
was captive because she couldn't leave
that money yeah I think that's probably
what she was talking about I remember
correctly [__] Michael Jackson's
Neverland Ranch I think it didn't it
have some fast food
joint on it um I don't know if they were
open all time no I don't think so okay I
know it it had a movie theater had a
movie theater on it had that had 50
seats in it yeah and it had a little
train and it had um just I don't know a
bunch of [__] yeah evidently there are
some billionaires that have compounds
that have fast food restaurants on them
yeah and parking lots and [__] roads
and AMC Theaters on it and it's for him
and his friends when they in an airport
you know where they can land their
planes right and thing is is I bet you
in that game there in in the Mansion
game I bet you his friends never even
come to visit him because they all got
that it's probably mostly a status thing
and when there's a party you know the
staff comes to open up [__]
McDonald's and [__] like that you know
but I mentioned mostly just
[__] most it's probably mostly closed
yeah just seems like such a waste of
space you know cuz I'm sure it's like
not used most of the time well I always
kind of felt like that about people like
rich people that had these big ginormous
like houses or compounds or whatever and
they're like not even there most of
they're not even there right so it just
seems like such a waste of space I I
think there might be taxes involved tax
write offs or something Investments
involved and U you're try they're trying
to spend as much money as possible
because they can't keep it in a bank
that type of thing so they have a
luxurious compound with a huge Manson
and a town all on private property with
no roads that lead to it other than
Supply roads everything's flown in
there's just airports yeah that's
evidently how [__] badass they can
get you can't drive to it weird huh yeah
I to to build it it had roads but then
they tore the roads down
right raceing all that [__] like kicking
the ladder down after climing yeah you
can't get to you can only get there by
aircraft and everything's flowing in man
that's some security that is yeah yeah
and then they got but then they want to
pretend like they're living a normal
person's life and leave the house and go
over to the [__] movie theater and
watch an AMC movie in an AMC movie
theater yeah but maybe it only has one
theater you know what I mean but that's
all if you notice how they how that
works all that shit's automatic yeah a
computer runs it yeah it's just live
streaming the [__] yeah and it even
changes the posters out yeah because
it's just an LCD screen right so you
don't even need an employee not really
if you're not if not paying if it's free
you don't need an employee it just runs
yeah you just to need somebody to set it
all up yeah set it all up and if the
power's on that [__] runs yeah and you
could probably select what movie you
want to see yeah
probably but yeah so um so after
this they um they got a search warrant
and on Neverland and they did that in
November of 2003 uh while Michael
Jackson was not home he was like a
shooting a video in Vegas or something
now a few days like as soon as he got
back they arrested him but he did post
bond which was $3 million now he comes
out in the in public obviously and says
you know it's all a big lie he didn't do
anything like that he also said and I
this really sounded like [__] to me
because there's like an interview where
he said he was quote unquote manhandled
by the police and he was saying to the
interviewer oh my you know they
dislocated my shoulder it's dislocated
right now look this is as far as I can
move it and it just sounded like
really um disingenuous was going to say
he just sounded like he was kind of like
complaining and whining like oh my God
I'm such a victim you know what I mean
it just kind of sounded like that we had
a good show tonight man there's a lot of
people in there yeah more than usual
well this is like a good topic I guess
yeah but so um because he had settled
out of court in
1993 he decided he was not going to do
it this time and he was actually G to
going to go to court and he was going to
like fight the allegations you know what
I mean um you know but yeah he did say
the cops like kind of beat him up and
dislocated his shoulder and stuff and
they said no that absolutely did not
happen and you know I'm not a big fan of
cops but I kind of believe them on this
occasion cuz Michael Jackson really did
seem a little bit like oh my God I'm so
you know he Hur me yeah it was just kind
of like that and I was like shut up they
did not so you know what I mean they
arrested me like a common criminal they
refed me up yeah he like you're fine
you're fine um handled his ass with kid
gloves they probably did like I said he
weighs a [__] 120 PBS not an ounce of
fight in Michael Jackson not an and I
imagine that some of the cops were
probably fans of his probably oh man
didn't do this he's getting [__] over
whatever I imagine that like cuz a lot
of people still think that that he's
innocent and like I said maybe he was I
don't know the dude's dead it's like
there's no way of knowing now I would
say no but I'm kind of leaning toward
her probably not I I mean just the just
the appearance of [__] that he did was
like so sketchy it does not make sense
yeah from South Park
it I I had forgotten about that we got I
want to see those old episodes again man
fing I think that I think South Park's
still on isn't it on like I think it's
still going I don't know where to see it
anymore which is crazy um had a newon
where they roasted Hollywood last week
and they say it's [__] great yeah I
kind of feel like much like The Simpsons
which I think is also still on um you
know if you've been on that long like
the quality is going to start to dip and
I heard that happen with South Park as
well but um so nobody's really talked
about it in a long time I used to watch
it like a long time ago well you now
have the Internet it's hard for South
Park to compete with the internet real
internet 90s internet it could compete
with it sure but you know I miss '90s
internet I don't yeah late ' 90s
internet I about the 90s there was a
Mystique to it DVD Dragon said sell my
ass to a billionaire for infinite
popey's Chicken on site okay all right
that's fair enough all right fair enough
all right but uh we still got a little
bit time on the show I want to take the
time to go ahead and pass the collection
played around we had a good show tonight
we got two good super chats and uh but
every dollar help helps us continue the
show and uh keeps me from having to pimp
my wife out to streammate and myself
myself you P yourself up too P myself
and and keeps you from having to go down
to downtown Sanford and blow all the
bikers for $20 yeah $20 $20
man Victor what have you done me
man this is so [__] great I am so
getting you that shirt for Christmas we
could just make that shirt and you
better wear it make that shirt okay we
can make one it's so much easier so much
easier just cuz then you can make it
black instead of I can make I can put it
on one of my [__] favorite [__] uh
muscle shirts on your muscle shirts yeah
different any color I want I just put on
a black one I just a white because I
already got I got the white paint for it
and everything yeah that's just um just
got to clear out one of those frames and
you print it up right there on that
printer and we'll [__] make it yeah
all I have to do is buy some uh cuz the
font wasn't that good you could come up
that's true I could come with some
better sh make it look a lot it didn't
look that cool and it should have had
like a pattern or something on there too
behind I can make it look kind of fancy
yeah kind of fancy yeah we'll definitely
do one because that would be a [__]
hilarious a [__] hilarious [__]
[__] shirt to stream in um so yeah so
in December of 2003 Michael Jackson was
charged with seven counts of child
molestation and two counts of
administering intoxicating agent for the
purpose of committing a felony in other
words giving kids
alcohol in order to facilitate the
molestation that was two of the counts
Victor says he'll buy that shirt okay
I'll s you one okay I'll s
you we haven't been playing the shirt
game lately I got to make up some new
shirt designs yeah we really didn't even
to do that we just haven't had time to
do iten time been too busy pimping our
asses out pimping trying to make money
pimping our asses out on
streaming sad but true yeah you can see
our videos on 13 cam spell it out 13 cam
yeah that's many vids on many vid we
have some on streamate too but they're
just me because they would they won't
let him they won't let me [__] sell
video on there for some reason for some
reason it's just a stipulation yeah on
on stream mate you can friend us on
stream mate it's uh or favorite us or
favorite us on stream mate Jen Tom cam
one word you'll see us you'll recognize
us we'll come right up Jen Tom cam I got
my blue hair on in the picture my blue
hair and my glasses so we've had fans
[__] show up there yeah and we always
kind of like that because it's like well
at least it's not random ass people yeah
that way we could we could actually talk
yeah cuz we talk in public for we can
talk in public for free yeah anything
adult we got to do in private you got
you're going to pay per minute for that
but it's just or we have a gold show
yeah sometimes I better I get a better
deal on gold CH but that well the
problem is that some people come in and
they want you to like talk about dirty
[__] for free for free like so they can
just sit there and jerk it and like not
pay you so there's that but I don't mind
if people just want to come in and
there's nobody else in there and they
just want to talk about regular [__]
that's right CU at least cuz it's kind
of boring just like sitting there and
like nobody coming in cuz sometimes
you're sitting there for like an hour
and nobody comes in you know what I mean
right it's like it's like wa watching a
shop yeah it's kind of like that yeah
you're just kind of like sitting there
you're trying to like get people to come
in like look I have a dildo and it's
like you know what I mean it's like we
got porn on over here we got music going
and [__] like that but you know what's
funny is that the dudes that do business
you don't even see them just boom they
get you yeah most of them they don't
yeah they don't even do a preamble
they're just like okay like let's go
like who's this what you looking for you
go I have fun okay yeah just do whatever
like like I said if they get too like
specific or picky then you know they're
probably not going to pay probably
they're they're just trying to get you
they're trying to get you to talk to
talk and for free you know what I mean
which I I've stopped doing yeah because
before I would start decid then I'm like
wait a minute they're just they're just
getting a bunch of [__] for free I don't
have time for this you know what I mean
but yeah so okay so he gets arrested and
charged right um and they also they put
a a bunch of additional charges on there
as well um some of them were a little
bit out there conspiracy involving child
abduction false imprisonment extortion
uh a couple of other things like that uh
so of course Michael Jackson pleaded not
guilty now had he been convicted which
spoiler alert he was not um the sentence
would have been he would have got up to
18 years I think yeah was what it was so
Michael Jackson you got probation
he didn't no he got uh exonerated oh no
I'm saiding if he had gotten convicted
as Michael Jackson he' have got
probation probably
probably they would have sent him to
some kind of
Camp yeah yeah PDF file yeah pray the
PDF
away [__] pray the PDF away yeah that is
that just like the first time that I
heard somebody use that euphemism I just
busted up laughing and I'm just like oh
my God that's amazing I'm going to I'm
going to use that Victor says I'm going
to be on there like can you talk about
Amelia
aart that's fine we can talk about
Emilia airheart all you want have we
ever done a show about Emilia aart I
think we did I thought we did too but
it's like it was probably like a really
long time ago yeah cuz she may have
survived the crash yeah I'm yeah that's
right we talked about that we're like we
were pretty sure she survived the crash
lat she ended up on a little little
bitty little [__] deserted island
like didn't they find her shoes they
found her shoes and like something she'd
owned it was on there yeah or like a
yeah like a compact lock or compact that
was hers they they believe pretty sure
that she landed that plane yeah out
there on that little bitty Island but
there was it's not around
anything yeah poor poor lady she would
have died of thirst there's no water
there yeah that would have sucked yeah
but yeah so um so yeah so as I said he
decides he's going to go to trial this
time because he kind of regretted uh
just the settlement last time so trial
started in February late February of
2005 now they actually did there was a
big um debate over whether they were
going to allow like the allegations from
the 1993 thing which like I said ended
in a settlement so that didn't go to a
trial so they're like they had a big
back and forth over whether they were
going to allow um you know evidence from
that but eventually they did um allow
that because they wanted to establish
obviously like a pattern of sexual abuse
that he had done this to like sever
people so here's the thing um both of
the guys that were in uh leaving
Neverland the documentary both of them
testified in
1993 and both of them denied that
Michael Jackson had ever done anything
to them as no he never touched us and
stuff like that and even like Wade when
he was a kid he like went on TV him and
his mom and his sister and you know in
no uncertain terms said that no he had
never done anything like that now the
second time
2005 um this was both of them said that
Michael Jackson called them and asked
them to testify on his
behalf now at this point they were both
adults Wade I believe was 22 and I think
James was a couple years
older um and Wade said that he would so
a lot of people have thought well you
know you're an adult now so you should
have said you know you should have
admitted that like but at this point
when I mean Wade explained in the
documentary where he's like look he
called and asked me to do it and he's
like and I still had like really
conflicting feelings about it because I
still kind of loved him um but like you
know as because he was like you know his
friend and everything like that and
they'd had this thing like when he was a
kid so he was like kind of [__] up
about it still and he almost I kind of
feel like he almost maybe deep down felt
like if he said something bad or he
admitted that Michael Jackson had done
that to him like it might like [__] up
his career right because like I said he
was quite famous in his own right as a
choreographer at this point and Michael
Jackson had been instrumental in kind of
getting his foot in the DM when he was a
kid so maybe he was afraid that [__] was
going to but at this point I he hadn't
even told his wife that Michael Jackson
had done that to him like Michael
Jackson he um he told her that had been
friends when he was a kid but she was
like oh well did he ever [__] with you
oh no no no he like denied it but then
like he told her later on and she was
just like [__] horrified but so Wade
testified on Michael Jackson's behalf in
2005 now apparently according to James
from the other guy from the documentary
Michael Jackson also called him and
asked him to testify on his behalf but
James would not do it even though I
don't think I think at this point he had
told his mom that what had happened to
him but I don't think he had told his
wife yet I think he told her later but
um but he's like yeah no I can't do that
and he said allegedly that Michael
Jackson got like really really mad at
him like over the phone and kind of like
threatened him a little bit like
something with something like not like
he was going to beat his ass or nothing
like that but like I'm going to sue you
or some [__] like that like he said that
he said some [__] like that like you
know and um he said that he just hung up
on him and and that was the end of
but um but then like later like I said
Wade came out and said that and admitted
what had happened to him but at this
point you know he was still kind of in
his
corner so uh so there was a thing where
uh Gavin was supposed to testify also
and for whatever reason like Michael
Jackson did not show up in court that
day even though he was supposed to so at
this point like the judge put out a
warrant for his arrest it's like you
know that's cont of court right cuz like
you're supposed to show up and he's not
there and he's like you know you were
out on $3 million Bond and we're going
to like you know snatch that away and
like put your ass back in jail if you
don't get here because you're supposed
to be here so so then Michael oh it's
Pooky hi Pooky we're talking about PDF
files guest guested on the show yeah she
doesn't know what a PDF file
is thank heavens I hope you never find
out what a PDF file is little Pooky but
um you're still
seven
not even she's only she's six yeah she's
six years old yeah a a little baby I
wonder why bam never comes on to show I
think it's almost she that's a teenager
for a cat yeah six yeah well kind of
yeah kind of yeah kind of so so Michael
doesn't show up he shows up like an hour
and 10 minutes later and he says that he
fell in the shower and bruised his
lung and that's why he's late yeah and
I'm just like how full of [__] I mean
come on now I fell down I hit myself
like this and I could breathe like this
I'm breathing in like
that that was pretty funny that was
pretty funny I can't go to
[Music]
court how do you bruise the lung I mean
I know how do you [__] pass out and
fall while you're walking and [__]
pull the side of your [__]
titty um well I don't know it's the same
thing
are you accusing me of being like
Michael Jackson but you saw that [__]
actually happen yeah I saw it she pulled
her
titty it was it was my rib cage actually
like the muscle of my rib cage not
exactly my it's better though now huh
finally it took like a week and a half
like to heal up I could barely move that
side of my body for like no it was it
was it was more than a week okay that I
could barely move that side of my body
and I was just like how the [__] did
that happen that's what happens when you
get old you just like like do some kind
of random [__] like that and it's like
then you're in bed for a week it sucks
yeah but um but yeah so he finally shows
up and then they have this other kid
whose name is Jason uh Francia now his
mom uh worked as a maid at Neverland and
he also said that Michael Jackson had
abused him like between the ages of
seven and 10 so um he said the big thing
was that every time Michael Jackson did
something to to him he would give him
some money so he wouldn't tell his mom
like you know what I mean and they did
another out of court settlement too but
he was another guy that um another kid
that testified that that was going on
now so like I said it's just kind of
like a lot of these kids did come
forward at first and say that he hadn't
hadn't molested them at first but then
came forward and said that he did and
then so that's kind of where all the
stuff came from about um you know them
just wanting money and [__] like that o
like windows are just popping up
everywhere also there was a guy who was
a security guard um at Neverland and he
said that he had seen Michael Jackson
performing oral sex on one of the kids
Jordan Chandler in the early 1990s where
were they um not really sure like I
think that um was it him that said that
he saw them in the hot tub like they
were naked the hot tub like the Jacuzzi
or whatever I know but he said that he
said that he also saw them like he saw
Michael Jackson like kissed the kid on
the mouth like french kiss him on the
mouth and then put his hand on his
crotch um and said that they asked him
why he didn't report that to the cops
and he said they didn't think that he
would believe them that they would
believe him yeah um how could they prove
it and then another maid said that she
saw Michael Jackson kissing boys too now
she said that she saw him kissing mcau
culin and mcau culin says that didn't
happen you know what I mean so I don't
really know now the thing about it and a
lot of people
um brought this up after the fact was
that they thought that these former
employees had kind of axes to grind
because some of them were allegedly
fired some of them had allegedly stolen
stuff like from the house or something
like that so you know the they are they
were able to argue that it's like
they're not trustworthy Witnesses
because they have a grudge against
Michael Jackson because he maybe fired
them or you know we got in trouble or
something like that so that was kind of
what a lot of people said but like I
said you know even if that was the case
maybe they did see the [__] I don't
really know but I don't I don't know
what was going on I don't know if they
were full of [__] or whatever um so
there was that now let me see what else
we have here cuz I'm trying to like skip
around cuz we've mentioned some of this
stuff cuz I mentioned the whole thing
about wine and like pop cans like soda
cans um which is weird because Michael
Jackson did that too because he liked to
drink but he didn't want his kids like
his actual kids to see him drinking so
he would put the wine in soda can so it
looked like he was drinking soda but
they also alleged that he was doing that
and like giving it to kids I don't know
about his kids but care if his kids are
seeing him do that what I yeah I don't
know that's some goofy [__] I mean it's
just wine too yeah although like some of
his um employees did say that he drank a
lot that they saw him drunk on many
occasions and that they had seen some of
the kids drunk as well not his kids but
you know the kids that were staying
there oh yeah they're all getting loaded
and he and he was like on a lot of
prescription drugs like painkillers and
stives and stuff expounds it yeah
exacerbates it which yeah which not you
know not
great so um Jordan Chandler apparently
who was the witness from the 1990 three
trial um he did not want to have
anything to do with it and he like
[__] left the country so you know
what I mean there was that cuz there was
like a whole bunch of other [__] that
was going on with that and um so yeah
now they actually called debie row
Michael Jackson's second wife she got
called to the witness stand too and the
story behind that the prosecution said
that she had actually been forced to
make like a
scripted video statement like you know
supporting him or whatever and so they
were going to put her on the stand
hoping that she would say some [__]
about him but she didn't um she actually
said that she didn't think that he was
guilty of anything and that all of these
people that were working for him and
stuff were what she called opportunistic
vultures who were trying to exploit him
so that didn't go the way the
prosecution uh thought uh Gavin arviso
he was uh he testified but he was
15 and he uh said that Michael Jackson
had given them wine uh showed them porn
and you know molested them and said that
Michael Jackson had masturbated him to
ejaculation after they both drank and
then he says that Michael Jackson said
if men do not masturbate they might rape
a girl
uh
okay's just trying to give him some
encouragement I I
guess I'm like what the [__] is he
talking about
okay now Gavin's younger brother also
said kind of shows you
Jackson's understanding of [__] male
sexuality well if you don't jerk off
then you're going to rape somebody
that's not how it works I mean I would
be really alarmed if somebody said that
to me I'm like all time with religious
people I'm like are you nocturnal
emission I'm like are you talking about
what you would do if you didn't because
get away from if I don't get some I'm
going to rape you yeah that's yeah might
have my way with you that's what I mean
it's like that's saying more about you
than about the world bro might be
projecting that's what I'm saying so
that's [__] up now Gavin's younger
brother also testified that he had seen
on two occasions Michael Jackson uh
showing his owner and masturbating in
front of both of them and saying
everyone does it and it's like why don't
you try it you know what I mean uh the
younger brother also said that he gave
them alcohol which as someone mentioned
earlier that he called Jesus Juice um
and showed them porn on the Internet so
there's that I wonder what he called
that those dirty movies this is some of
those dirty movies he probably does call
it a dirty movie although no he'd
probably come up with some like kind of
nice sounding eism for it let see some
of that sexual education films yeah
maybe that's what yeah yeah sexed that's
another thing and that was another thing
when I was watching that documentary
about different kinds of PDF files that
was one of the things that's in there
they said they'll always try to like
minimize it or justify it by calling it
like sexual education like I was
educating them or like about so or
helping them it's called grooming yeah
it's that well yeah that's what normal
people say but it's like that they
always try to kind of like minimize it
you know what I mean and it's kind of
interesting too because he would there
was these these couple interviews that
he did where they were asking him about
these about the abuse and he's
like he kind of made a he he was like he
said pedophile but then he said oh who's
the Jack the Ripper in the room almost
as though he was trying to say like a
pedophile wasn't as bad as that you know
what I mean like the way he worded it
was like really really weird but like I
said it was just kind of like always
trying to like minimize like it's not as
bad as people are saying you know and
they said that's really really common
thing for like PDF files to do now it
should be noted and this came up at the
trial and was probably one of the things
that was instrumental in getting Michael
Jackson acquitted of all the charges was
that um this family the um the uh what
what's their what I say their last name
was the Aro family is that in the past
they had done things like um like they
sued JC Penney because they said that
Gavin and the brother whose name is star
and their mom were beaten up in the
parking lot of the JC penne after they
stole some [__] like the security guards
like beat them up in the parking lot and
so they sued JC Penney for like a bunch
of money um beat them up yeah how they
defined that I don't really know okay
but it's like so they apparently got a
settlement out of that so they're trying
to paint it like this is a family that
are scammers like they just go around
like saying oh my God they beat me up
and they're just trying to get somebody
to settle you know what I mean and like
get a bunch of money so they were trying
to like say that that's what this family
did in this case but like I said I don't
know if that's the case or not but they
did bring that up at the trial that
these kind of that they had done this
kind of stuff before you know what I
mean um so there was that yeah just cuz
those guys [__] did that doesn't mean
the other [__] didn't happen that yeah
and that's a scammer sees that a scammer
sees that situation and goes Ching oh we
got that's what I mean and in some ways
I kind of feel like if he really was
doing that and people knew about it then
that leaves him more open to Blackmail
and stuff like that because people have
information on you like they're like
well I have pictures of you doing that
[__] or whatever so it it it it would
even be worse if he was actually doing
it yeah because you know if it's kind of
hard to like convict like an innocent
person of that kind of stuff like and
especially like something like child
sexual abuse and stuff like that where
there's like so little solid evidence
and that was one thing in uh you know
the trial this trial where he got
acquitted was that the jury basically
said you know we didn't really see any
really strong evidence that he had done
anything wrong although two of the
jurors later on came out and said H we
kind of thought he did it but you know
everybody else was kind of on board with
it and we didn't want it to be a hung
jury going to be this big thing so they
kind of just got strong armed into going
along with everybody else no hard
evidence that's why I said earlier on in
the show is that you can make the ACC
you can make the accusation I like the
maid oh I saw something I know it's
wrong how are you GNA prove it that's
what I mean it's like and it doesn't
mean he's got money and all these
lawyers it's just GNA it's going to be a
nightmare of proven that you never will
you need hard evidence and in this case
video that would work video yeah uh
multiple witnesses kidss that are saying
oh man what that man did to me and then
they can name where it was you you might
even be able to fight that all those
kids are [__] lying you
know video would be the way to do it I
think that's why they go
after the uh um underage prawn industry
yeah Rings they go after them because
one that you can prove that you got it
on video
right you know and it calls a lot of
attention and then as that [__] is
disseminates through the internet in a
way the kids abused multiple times by
everybody that's seeing it yeah so you
know what I mean it's gonna because
they're
like they're like [__] vampires
sucking up all that material
yeah evidently that [__] was happening
on Facebook in private groups that that
was like one of the easiest places to do
it like you could talk your way in and
fire your went this is according to one
of these
Facebook um Facebook employees and they
weren't turning them in though they were
just kind of like shutting them down and
[__] right and he said he saw some wild
[__] he saw one of them where was little
boys were killing and torturing animals
for money in private Facebook groups
people were paying them to go out and
get animals and kill them Jesus Christ
man these are like 13 14 year old boys
taking snakes and smacking the snakes on
the ground and [__] [__]
cutting things open they'd make several
hundred dollars for each one you know
people were in that group adults were
sending them money for the next
feature weird [__] was going on in there
yeah yeah he would I never even think of
that yeah I would like why why would I
[__] want to see that but there's
some [__] freaks out there yeah
there's some [__] freaks out there
yeah but you
know I would never well you know it was
just kind of like that that [__]
that had that video of like the kittens
you know what I mean that they made that
documentary about don't fck with cat
zipl yeah yeah that was [__] up that's
actually mild compared to well and that
and that dude ended up being like an
actual murderer yeah too there was some
something that somewhere in Eastern
Europe videos were emerging of [__]
some kid teen early teenager putting
cats inside a cages pouring gasoline on
them and setting them on fire do yeah f
videotape it they were looking for that
they were looking for that
kid well good I hope they [__] hung
him upside down by his feet and peeled
all his skin off murder Hornet sent me a
YouTube video show about a case it's
called Uh I think it's called one [__]
one [__] 12 puppies where a guy kills a
pregnant dog or a dog that just gave
birth and and all the puppies and [__]
and beats the dog to death with a
[__] some kind of tool I forgot what
it was she was was chained to a tree and
he cut the puppies open and stuff and
was jerking his [__] with the puppy guts
and stuff and just he was [__] crazy
they were looking for that guy they they
think that might have been somewhere in
Eastern Europe they were looking for
that guy I don't think they ever saw his
face don't listen to this pokeing yeah
don't L that but that was like a video
going around for a while so they got
some sick dudes well yeah and um
me being exmilitary and
[__] basically defense contractor
weird sides of the defense Contracting
I'm
not I'm not
real I'm not real confident in the white
man's law really the way [__] happens if
I catch somebody like that I'm I'm G
deal with that [__] myself you can't let
somebody like that walk around they're
too [__] dangerous you really can't
they're too [__]
dangerous they do that to animals and
[__] they do that to humans they're
thinking they're working up to humans
even if there's only a 25% chance I'm
not going to take that chance you gone
man I'm going to get
you I'm going to get you I mean I can't
blame you yeah and they ain't going to
find out a piece that
dude you feed him to an alligator yeah
just I got ways I got ways you know I
got ways
I I got too much [__] field skills
and
[__] dressed too many deer and
[__] yeah and I ate everything that I
killed but you eat everything but
including the people yeah
[Laughter]
just kidding I thought I'd throw that in
there and see and see if you R and see
if you rolled with it I'd have to be
real
hungry I'd have to be real hug I imagine
people probably and I'd have to be
really pissed off Hannibal Lector style
you know you got to I'm going eat you
and [__] you down to drink yeah yeah
strengthened myself and to you you
Island Boys know what I'm talking about
the ma the Maui and and the [__]
micronesians and the and the the Sans
they
know they eat a [__] the
Mexicans too the Mexicans eat a
[__] on a heartbeat oh I'll eat
a [__] yeah yeah man the Aztecs
are cannibals ritual
cannibals cut your heart out and then
eat
you Ben says that prot go to waste well
yeah juries routinely convict people on
weak evidence because everyone hates
child molters yeah but like not in this
case though like but I kind of feel not
in Michael Jackson's case yeah like he
got away with it you know what I mean
it' have to be Rock Solid
and like I said okay so they did search
his house and they did find like I said
they didn't find hardcore Kitty prawn
but they did find like some kind of
weird books that They seized that had
like naked pictures of boys in there
that's cuz that's all he could get right
so yeah maybe he was maybe he was smart
enough to know it's like I don't I don't
I can't have a whole stash of like of
this stuff in here what's he going to do
he's going to go buy it himself they
going to say yeah I so that [__] to
Michael Jackson yeah it's like everybody
recognize everybody c yeah or you going
to hire somebody go go get some prawn
for me yeah no they're not good then
he's got dirt on you right so he can't
know that's what I'm saying but at least
he had that much need what would we need
proms for he's got the kids and they're
like model quality kids yeah yeah that's
what I mean maybe he do like even feel
the need he like well I got these couple
little like books but yeah you know what
I mean yeah I got the real thing so he's
not worried about it what I got is
better yeah maybe maybe he thought that
of course
so and like I said they did find a
photograph in there um because I saw
like the the list of all the stuff that
they had seized from the house and they
did find a photograph in there of a
naked kid that they're pretty sure was
one of the ones that uh that hung out
with him all the time so you know so
there's that that seems a little
definitive I'm just going to say so yeah
so after that happened like I said he
was uh acquitted of all charges uh the
jury just didn't think that there was
enough evidence and so he got away with
it and um like I said he didn't want to
go back to Neverland because he thought
that the police and FBI being in there
had you know messed it all up so he
never went back to it even though as far
as I know he still owned it like at his
death because I think it was part of his
estate uh you know after after he died
but um you know it just it it kind of
did still affect his career though like
I said you know he tried to before he
died he was kind of trying to uh jump
start his career he was still super
famous and still super rich obviously
but he'd you know gone down a little bit
because of all the allegations so he was
trying to kind of do a comeback type of
thing when he died but because of all
the stuff even though he'd gotten
acquitted um he couldn't really find
like any sponsors or anything like that
cuz really companies really didn't want
to be associated with him just because
you know the not a great look so there's
that so then in June of 2009 uh he died
now the drug that killed him was and I'm
not sure if I'm pronouncing this right
but it's called propal it's kind of like
Camp guy said something about it earlier
it's actually it's not even just a
sedative they use it for like anesthesia
for surgery so it's it's hardcore [__]
knocks you out and I believe he had
gotten to the point at least according
to Physicians or like staff and things
like that where he had worked up such a
tolerance to it that he was using like a
lot of it like to sleep because of his
bad insomnia pretty much so apparently
like I said he um had done like the day
before he died he was doing a rehearsal
for the you know comeback to her type of
thing they were doing and everybody said
he seemed normal like he seemed like
kind of Health he kind of joked about
having laryngitis or something but they
said said he seemed completely
fine and so then like he went home and
he couldn't
sleep and so he got uh you know his
doctor at the time who he actually got
through I think this doctor they hooked
him up with the doctor through the um
the like production company or something
like that that handled his shows in the
UK mhm and they got this doctor I guess
I I'm not really sure like how that all
worked out but this doctor like he's at
the house and apparently Michael Jackson
is like he can't sleep and he's trying
to get um the dude to give him the you
know the the [__] that he that he wants
he called it he called it milk I think
in medical parlons it's called milk of
Amnesia yeah you know what I meann right
so that's kind of so that's what he
called it as well makes you forget um no
well it just like knocks you the [__]
out like I said it's used for it's like
an anesthetic like for surgery like they
use it to put people out for surgery is
what it's not just like a regular
sedative you know what I mean so um you
know it's kind of a pretty hardcore one
so he must have been under a lot of
stress yeah yeah yeah to be knocking
himself out like that yeah he's worried
about [__] worried about his career he's
worried about those boys yeah I bet you
he worried about getting caught I mean
maybe so yeah but yeah so the doctor con
was Conrad Murray was his name so he
according to him he's like um he gave
him like some sedatives and [__] but you
know and was kind of staying with him
but it wasn't working like he was still
just laying there awake and he was just
kept asking him give me the milk you
know what I mean which is the the propop
fall and um so finally Dr Murray is just
kind of like uh okay fine like he didn't
want to give it to him at first
apparently but then he's just like he
kept asking for it so he's just like
okay fine so he injected him with it
it's like you know it's injectable he
gave him 25
Mig and then you know he finally fell
asleep so then Conrad Murray said that
he left to like go go to the bathroom or
something like that and then when he
came back Michael Jackson was not
breathing now interestingly this is kind
of why he got in trouble for this [__]
he said that he tried to revive him like
doing CPR but he's a doctor right
to do CPR you're supposed to have them
on a hard surface like a floor but he
left them up on the bed and he was doing
a thing where he like put his hand under
him like that was trying to that's like
not the way you're supposed to do it you
know what I mean um I saw the guy though
he looked like a quack to me yeah well
that's kind of what yeah yeah and I
don't even think that he's a doctor
anymore because I think they took his
license a lot of a lot of doctors are
nothing more than a glorified drug
dealer that's a lot of them well this
one was for sure yeah but yeah so uh so
it wasn't working so then he calls to
the staff because obvious you know this
is a massive the place that he lives
he's got like a staff you know what I
mean so they so basically like he calls
911 finally but the thing that they find
out later like okay so he didn't call
911 at first they asked him why and he
said oh well the house doesn't have a
landline and I don't know what the
House's address is so I didn't call them
but they did find out that on they
looked at his cell phone records and he
had called a bunch of other people like
after finding Michael Jackson but he
didn't tell the cops that he had called
all these other people you know what I
mean so he didn't even end up calling
911 like a security guard did and this
was like a couple hours later like an
hour and a half later like after he was
Michael Jackson was laying there like
not
breathing so the paramedics get there at
like 12:30 in the afternoon
and when they get there he's not
breathing he doesn't have a pulse they
did CPR on him for 42 minutes like while
they were at the house now the attorney
for Conrad Murray because he did get in
trouble for this [__] said that he was
still breathing when they took him out
of the house but the paramedics said
that he wasn't they said when they got
there he was in full cardiac arrest and
they didn't see any change like in route
to the hospital they took him to the
hospital and they you know the medical
team there like tried to resuscitate him
for about an hour but it didn't work so
they finally pronounced him dead at 2:26
p.m. now so then they take him they do
they did an autopsy and basically they
said you know no evidence of trauma or
Foul Play but the Los Angeles County
Coroner classified the death as a
homicide because of the amount of drugs
that were in his system so basically
they said he was otherwise healthy they
said he didn't really have any health
problems or anything like that and that
it wasn't um anything to do with his
heart it was you know or or anything
like that it was it was the drugs so
they uh the LAPD and the DEA uh both
looked into the case and looked into all
the doctors and then they decided to
turn it over to the prosecutors now the
Jackson family believed that he had been
murdered which
not really I don't think the doctor
intended to kill him obviously but
that's kind of what ended up happening
so what ended up happening was that
Conrad Murray was arrested and charged
with I believe the charge was
involuntary manslaughter and he was
found guilty um and he got a four-year
sentence although I think he only served
two or three years of it because of good
behavior however he was uh stripped of
his medical license and rightly so
probably and uh then that's what kind of
happen they said that they when they
went through his house they found a
bunch of bottles of that propop fall
stuff like some of them were empty and
like some of them and like a lot of
doctors wouldn't even give it to you
because it's like really strong you know
what I mean like you can't just take
that [__] it's kind of like he was but
yeah but he was getting it somewhere so
they actually I think they was he doing
his own injections um I think he was
Finding doctors to do it because I think
during the investigation like this was
the only guy got in trouble but I think
they also investigated like nine other
doctors that they were trying to like
determine if they had given him some of
it it's not illegal but you know yeah
what's controlled substance and you're
not supposed to probably that's probably
not the proper application for yeah it's
not really it's not really you know it's
probably overkill for them uh yeah big
time so that's weird it's funny he
couldn't just secure it on his own and
just injected on his own he he had to
have been yeah he's not going to have a
doctor every [__] night Knight coming
and do that to him he's injecting his
own Yeah well yeah and he's it's not
that hard to getting somebody to like
Supply [__] for him yeah he's got a
black market or gray Market supplier a
doctor is supplying him yeah clandestine
like yeah here's three or four
bottles be careful that kind of [__]
yeah apparently like I don't know if
this was Doctor to the Stars one of
those guys yeah I don't know if this was
the first time that he ever took it like
and he's like oh that's some good [__]
but they said while he was in Germany he
actually went to an
anesthesiologist and had him give that
stuff to him like to help him sleep yeah
and then so he said what the
anesthesiologist would do he would give
him that at night like to get him sleep
and then he would give him like some
other [__] in the morning like to wake
him back up yeah proba math like during
the tour methan and that was like in the
90s yeah methamphetamine probably
probably yeah something like that so
yeah he was on all kind of like a a
cocktail of different stuff yeah meth
for for y'all that don't know methan
phetamine has been around for a long
long time in the 30s in Europe there was
no restrictions on it you could get it
anywhere yeah and uh they thought it was
just a miracle drug if you felt if you
felt bad inject some meth
methamphetamine you'd be fine pick you
right up [__] mustache man of the
Germans of the BET cross was [__] oh
they used they basically did the same
thing to him which it's sign of being
under a lot of [__] stress especially
after he lost the battle of K during
operation Barbarosa when he [__]
attacked stupidly attacked Russia and
got his ass handed to him uh they
knocked him out with morphine at night
and they woke him up with
methamphetamine I can't imagine yeah
living that kind of Life yeah that's
what he did I mean that's gonna and he
it can't last most people think he had
third stage syphilis in in remission
yeah I've heard that yeah he he he he
exhibited a lot of personality traits of
a person that kind of halfway beat beat
syphilis and put it into remission you
end up being real mentally rigid once
you make up a mind you make up your mind
on something you can't reverse your
decisions become kind of lizard
like that kind of fits the descriptions
of his
behavior you know he thought he could
win the war just through his
will yeah yeah and he's getting like
super delusional all of his decisions
were correct he could he could never
reverse any of his decisions that kind
of [__] that's
syphus or or just being an [__] or
both his doctor was named Dr
Morel who was a famous syphus doctor
before the war right so his doctor was a
syphilis doctor he had syphilis and he
was and it was a doctor that was giving
him all VTO molon B which was [__]
meth yeah yeah Allison said if you need
propal just to sleep you need to cut
down on the Red
Bull yeah like I said that's like some
hardcore [__] that's like he's got under
a lot of stress for uh I'm probably
what's happening at this time he's
nearly nearing 50 he's 50 when he died
he knows that his time is short you
can't play the Michael Jackson game
Beyond 50 okay true nature is g to catch
that with you you're not going to look
like a skinny little [__] 14-year-old
Peter Pan it's not possible even with
plastic surgery it's not possible they
speculated too that he might have had
anorexia oh yeah be because he like um
was underweight although when he died
they said he was a normal weight but he
did have issues like with um being
really skinny he wanted to look like had
of a dancer's body but like I said he
wanted to look like Peter Pan probably
yeah and wanted to do it naturally
probably you could do it with certain
hormones but but they just said he
didn't eat much yeah that's the worst
way to do it and and and what's weird is
that he's on all these drugs and he's
trying to stay thin like that and he's
dancing and then he's got to go on tour
where's this physical training routine
is he doing weight is he doing weights
is he doing is he just dancing that's
it that's what I'm asking you oh I don't
know you don't
okay it's not possible I didn't really
look into his whole Fitness routine
there had to have been something like a
fitness routine if not he'd have gotten
fat and you got your metabolism is
slowing down by 50 yeah the fat the
weight's just going to
come that's why maybe he said he went
anorexic but still you can starve an
person they don't lose a lot of
weight the cellular function the
mitochondria kind of slowed down you
know what I mean you don't your
metabolism is
crawling um but about uh propop fall
Victor says we use it a lot to sedate
people on ventilators H yeah that's what
I mean it's like so it's used for that
it's not usually used for a sleep a as
far as I am aware but that's what he was
using it for when his quack doctors gave
it ended up killing him he liked it
ended up killing him like he got too
much of it and yeah he just went to
sleep and then DVD Dragon said his
physical training was deadlifting
12-year-olds yeah yeah yeah maybe so
yeah maybe so and then um Ben said that
maybe he was having money problems
toward the end well okay as far well as
far as I know yeah like he still had
money like he wasn't broke or nothing
like that he would never be poor no no
um they said when he died this is at
least according to
Wikipedia um that let's see the net
worth in 2007 which was 2 years before
he died was
236.14
67.6 million in assets that included
Neverland Ranch which he still and he
owned he owned it out right he and yeah
and he also had a 50% share of Sony ATV
music publishing catalog so he wasn't
going anywhere but he also had a lot of
debts $331 million in debts that catalog
would have gotten uh less and less
valuable later on as the internet
[__] yeah so um
no but if he owned
Neverland the upkeep on that was
probably a lot oh I imagine it was yeah
so you can't keep that ranch without an
income or he'd burn through that 200
million that he had you know pretty
quick I think you probably pay about a
million dollars a year just an upkeep on
Neverland oh easily um and then you know
his spending habits and
[__] if he didn't have an income he'd
have to get Neverland and I don't think
he wanted to do that yeah he' never be
poor he moved away from it like after
the trial okay but um but he still owned
it like when he died might have been an
excuse maybe he knew he was eventually
going to have to get rid of that maybe
because maybe he really couldn't afford
it I heard that it was mostly turned off
all the time yeah you know cuz the
electric bill this all [__] trains
and [__] right this is what it's but
this is what it's saying cuz I was kind
of interested what like what his um
estate was like when he died
it says the value of the Sony ATV music
publishing is estimated at this point to
be$ 1.5
billion uh so Jackson's share would be
$750 million which would have got him an
annual income of $80
million um so they so I guess that
someone bought it out for like $750
million but it's most of his stuff went
to um Charities and he has like the
Michael Jackson Family Trust so he could
have retired yeah and been all right
Tammy said didn't he own the rights of
the Beatles music yeah he did see he he
could have been all right then and just
retired in in Neverland yeah that was
kind of where a lot of his money came
from was all of the um the music and
stuff he that he owned what's
funny be on YouTube and I'd watch these
guys do these explorations of these
abandoned mansions all over the world
there's beautiful mansions and some of
the [__] are weird Mansions crazy
looking Mansions the Mansion game is
quite strange
the only people that are impressed with
Mansions are people that don't own
Mansions a guy who owns Mansions all his
friends have Mansions so they don't give
a [__] they don't go from one Mansion to
another they don't go visit another dude
in his
Mansion you know mean so you buy the
Mansion you're kind of [__] then you
got this big thing and they end up only
living in a little tiny part of it like
it would be an apartment yeah the what
are you gonna do with all this they
can't they don't ever use the rest of it
they they they have it shut down it's
like in
mothball it'll have bowling alleys you
know bowling lanes and [__] swimming
pools and [__] [__]
garages and a lot of and and a lot of
the guys that have them don't even have
really like families they might have a
wife but the kids are gone so you know
kind of a and
then if he loses the Mansion the Mansion
sits on the market and never sells again
because dudes that buy Mansions don't
want used Mansions they want their own
brand new Mick mansion
built in in a location to their
specification so there are a [__]
abandoned mansions every [__] where
maybe we should go squat in one yeah
yeah find one with the power still on
those guys will go into a match and goes
yeah this match has been been vacant for
13 years and a motherfucker's furnished
yeah it's furnished I me tell tell you
can tell that people have like rummaged
through it right there's nothing really
valuable in it anymore you
know but uh and you know you can't heat
or cool it I guess yeah but some of them
looked pretty good because they weren't
obviously broken into right you but you
could get into it I guess a window would
be open yeah and guys would open and
close the windows they would get out
sometimes they're vandalized but a lot
of times they're not they look okay you
could live in it so it's kind quite
shocking you look at it you go like man
nobody's been in that thing for 13 years
that kind of stuff creepy yeah DVD
Dragon said the proper people is a great
herel yeah that's one that's one of the
channels I that that's I was going to
say I'm pretty sure that we've seen yeah
cuz I like I like a lot of the um the
urban exploration like all the dead
malls and stuff like that yeah who's
that one guy s that does I like I like
his stuff too yeah Dan Bell's the best
one for the well yeah Dan Bell's the
best one yeah for dead malls but he
doesn't put up as many dead malls as he
used to used he does a lot of live
streams though yeah like driving around
Baltimore um yeah Allison said you can't
properly heat a small house never mind a
mansion yeah yeah I can't imagine like
with the [__] upkeep it just seems
like such a waste like I said they look
cool but I wouldn't want to take care of
it they say you end up living in a
little small part of it anyway well yeah
but like I said what are you going to do
like you can't oh I'm going to roller
skate through the whole house like what
the [__] and you don't have guests right
because all your friends have their own
mansions and what are you going to do
invite the Hoy pooy the Rabel the people
you met at the bar you going invite them
into your Mansion no well and then you
got to have a staff cuz you got to have
like people to clean it and like you
know maintain the [__] cuz I'm not going
to [__] do it that's to run one 247 and
use the whole thing you got to have a
whole it's like running a business yeah
it's just like that just seems like way
too much trouble cuz I kind of feel like
the whole point the whole fun of having
a lot of money is being able to buy your
way out of all that pain in the ass [__]
so it's like why would you want to like
have even more of that pain in the ass
[__] you got have cleaning people coming
and clean [__] man I would probably go
live in hotels yeah so I never i' never
have to clean anything that would be
awesome they got people that do that
just you know what I mean I think like I
I would just try to buy my way out of
every like stupid chore that I don't
want to do and all that kind of stuff
Howard Hughes owned all kinds of
mansions and never went never went to
him he lived in a hotel top of the S the
S top of the the Sands or the dunes yeah
in in in Las Vegas he rented it I don't
think that's probably the rout he rented
it yeah cuz then you could just go all
over the world and just like get a nice
hotel room and just stay there for as
long as you wanted to stay and then be
like [__] it it's maybe he bought it I
think he bought that whole building uh
it's been a long time since I've you
know some clothes in a suitcase and just
kind of go wherever you want to go I
think that'd be pretty awesome and you
wouldn't have to clean [__] that'd be
cool yeah I think he bought a I think he
bought that hotel yeah just lived in it
and had a staff I think he did too yeah
all right so I guess we're going to wrap
it up I'm surprised that we actually got
through most of this yeah information
because it was a lot um but you know
it's a actually I thought the show was
going to be like five hours long but
it's not it's 3 hours and 45 minutes
that's not too bad but uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this disc
discussion about the Michael Jackson
controversy and you know if you want to
do a poll I'll put a poll up and see if
like whoever thinks he's it seemed like
most people did think he was guilty but
I did when I was looking at the other
videos like it seemed like a lot of
people were just like leave Michael
alone he didn't do it you know what I
mean and I'm just kind of like I don't
know I think he probably did do that
[__] but uh but yeah victure said so
glad I made it today great show a thank
you so much yeah I kind of had a lot of
fun with this one even though it's kind
of a [__] up topic but uh but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by thank
you for all your super chat that's very
much appreciated and we'll see you guys
again on Friday night for the Sidetrack
show so that'll be fun hopefully you
guys can all make that and I guess
that's it we'll see you Friday good
night